we're back on the grind boys that's
Sigma grind energy get that holiday
mentality over Joey we're back working
now man no more fun don't remind me
hey yo welcome back to another episode
of the trash taste podcast I'm Joey and
I'm with the boys as per usual guys I'm
trying to blow people's ears out yes of
course I'm trying to get some energy in
what I like to call like this period is
like the holiday hangover you know
it kind of is because you because that's
such an accurate time yeah this this
holiday was weird for me I'll tell you
why it was okay go on tell me why it's
weird because I did nothing isn't that
good and that was the weirdest thing
I've experienced all year I think that's
how you know we're [ __ ] overworked
ourselves it's just it's just like oh
what I'm sitting here and it's like what
do I do with my hands it was so weird
right because uh we're coming back from
Christmas and New Year's I remember it
was like the
27th or something or 20th 28th of like
December yeah and I was I remember like
I remember thinking God we've been like
we're not film trash tasteful I feel
like three weeks it was seven days and I
was just like holy [ __ ] I feel like I've
been off work for a month now what the
hell man oh my God yeah I mean like I
for one experienced probably the worst
Christmas and New Years of my goddamn
life
uh because I I mean I mentioned it very
briefly but I had a gastroenteritis or
stomach flu and it was probably using
like the cursive version of that what do
you mean it's a stomach flu why are you
losing cursive because it's more serious
yeah because gastroenteritis sounds way
cool I was gonna say when you because
you did an Instagram post I was like the
[ __ ] is that I Googled it I was like
what this what the [ __ ] I didn't say
stomach flu well because I didn't know
because that's I've always known it as
that term I never knew it was called
stomach flu yeah so people will like
means some people like do you mean
stomach flu I'm like oh that makes more
sense this is literally just a Winnie
the Pooh meme with uh yeah
so uh I had the stomach flu
um which for those of you don't know is
like kind of like a worser version of
food poisoning That's the only way to
destroy illness
an actual illness
um but yeah how do you get it uh so I
mean there's a lot of ways you can get
it um for one like the most common way
is kind of like food poisoning where you
like you just eat something bad or you
drink something that was kind of
official layer yeah it's like food
poisoning except if it was like built
like Mayweather you know it's like it's
like this thing like punches the crap
out of it you can die from food
poisoning right can you die from stomach
flu or is it kind of different just more
of a I think I don't think you can die
from stomach flu but you can develop
other illnesses so like a lot of people
who have like stomach ulcers for example
and stuff like that get it as a a result
of like really bad stomach flu so
basically I got that and I was basically
bedridden for about eight days
um and I've had and I've had stomach flu
before like I've I've gotten in in like
Australia and like the US and stuff like
that but never in Japan and like
normally even like in the worst like
kind of like food poisoning right the
worst is like maybe a couple of days and
then you get it out of your system and
you're good but like this I don't man
this this boy wanted to hang around for
the holidays he was just like oh you're
alone at home Arc is overseas I'll be
your company this holiday season this
either you're just home alone just dying
I was just dying like Christmas Eve for
example was probably like the peak and
it just felt like I was just getting
stabbed in the stomach and I was going
to the toilet every like five minutes
just like vomiting or just like hissing
through my ass and it was I was
absolutely horrible
um yeah and so it got really bad around
day five and yeah
[Music]
day five it got it got really bad in day
five so bad to the point where I was
like I don't know if this is like a
stomach flu anymore I feel like this is
something worse so I went to the
hospital yeah
um imagine [ __ ] Christmas Eve I'm I'm
at the [ __ ] hospital because my
stomach is dying you were like an old
man would approach you in the street and
give you something to make you believe
that Christmas is real yeah on the way
to the hospital yeah free trip to the
hospital he's like oh I've given you a
rice cake Christmas uh Christmas cheer
does exist yeah congratulations thank
you so much he said instead of an old
man it was a it was an old man in a
doctor's outfit you're telling me that
yeah I just had a really bad case of the
stomach flu he gave me some medicine to
be like yeah you'll probably be fine in
a couple of days
um and then yeah I finally got better
around the first or the second of
January so how do you get stomach flu is
it from eating something dodgy yeah
okay so there's a couple of speculations
yes uh obviously obviously I had a lot
of time yeah to look this up
ain't doing anything else yeah I'm just
lying in bed for eight days I'm like
well I guess I'll learn something new in
the medicine field too yeah
um so I looked it up um like the most
common way is like again kind of like
food poisoning where it's like you
either eat something that was maybe like
a little undercooked or a little bit you
know rotten or you know you drink
something where your stomach just like
doesn't take it and stuff like that yeah
another way you can get it is it's
called a stomach flu because it's
actually like
um you can get it from someone else oh
oh so someone with like a a stomach flu
say coughs for example yeah and you're
in the vicinity there is a chance you
can catch it that way as well oh Jesus
um so I think though what happened was
that like I know exactly the day it
happened because two days before uh I
went out drinking with a couple of my
friends
um Manu uh yeah uh O'Hara good friend of
ours um Maki mayline's husband and then
my other Japanese friend we went out
drinking and I know it was that day
because when I told the boys I was like
yo I got the stomach flu and it might
have been on this day all three of them
are like yeah we're kind of sick as well
oh God so it was definitely that day it
was either something we ate or something
we drank but it's weird because we
didn't eat anything raw that day maybe
just think that wasn't so much it must
have been something that was like maybe
undercooked or wasn't stored properly
and it does happen a lot more in Japan
than you think as I am a testament to
this uh it does happen a lot or anything
but what's so weird is that like I've
never had any kind of like food
poisoning or anything like that in Japan
let alone something that bad like again
it's like I've had it before but it
lasted maybe like a day or two at most
but this guy was just Clinging On to
dear life and he was just like I'm gonna
make your holidays absolutely miserable
this year so I definitely uh I got a PB
of the worst Christmas that's for sure
um you know I thought it was bad enough
that I was shoveling [ __ ] in the snow uh
one New Year's Eve in a blizzard no
that's nothing compared to this this was
definitely he by follow us I mean I can
laugh about it now but yeah man was
horrible at least like my Saving Grace
was that it didn't happen during a week
where I had a lot of stuff like we
didn't have anything isn't that sad that
you're like so sad didn't you say that
the symptoms started to come on on the
23rd yeah literally which is the day
after the last trash taste for Courtney
so luckily like the only thing I had
planned was that you know because it was
the last week of December right yeah so
I was like oh okay we've got no trash
taste we've I have no filming you know
scheduled or anything like that yes so
so I filled up that entire week with
like you know seeing friends or like you
know I was supposed to go up to Sendai
to like see my grandma over the New
Year's I had to cancel all of that
um and just wither away alone in bed on
during the last week of 2022 so my year
ended uh great so I hope uh you guys and
everyone watching had a better holiday
than I did but how polite of the illness
to wait for the day after you film is
you know he was he was he was like you
know what you know what the boys need
him the boys need it okay let him go for
that yeah I know and then I'm coming
forward I remember like I was saying I
was telling this to God earlier today
and in my head I was just like man that
is the most Japanese salary man thing
I've ever said in my life it's like well
at least I didn't miss out on work you
know because everyone knows that's the
most important baby I feel like I took
my holidays I willed my body into
not twice like recently not really felt
like I was gonna be sick and I was like
no really well how so do you know you
wake up with the throat it's a little
bit like oh no oh no I actually had the
same holiday and I feel like I I [ __ ]
willed it I was like yeah [ __ ] dare
dude [ __ ] I just got back from my
holiday I was like I need to work I want
to work
if I remember I was just like no I'm not
I'm not even giving this attention I'm
not even gonna I'm gonna pretend like
this isn't happening yeah and then
literally next day I was fine yeah sick
the day after I was like oh God it's
coming back and like no no it's like it
comes back when you least expect it it's
like you forgot about me I'll take a
little throat thing I'll I'll chill out
I'll drink a ton of water um I'm gonna
ignore this yeah I'm fine oh actually
yeah I don't know if this is
100 [ __ ] that I've just made up in
my head to tell myself that I'm I'm
strong enough to [ __ ] this thing over
see but it's weird right because like
there's I remember there's like uh and
again I don't know how true these are
but like I've heard you know on and off
about like yeah that whole thing of like
you know if you think hard enough that
like oh that's all [ __ ] the disease
goes away then it actually goes away
in reference like depression zero yeah
it's like cancer zero people realize
they could think it away
this is going to be like mind over
matter you know give me example one of
why we get canceled by a medical
association
no we're not saying this we know it's
dumb as much
it's just a feeling because that's
exactly the same thing happened to me uh
this holiday where like early on like
Joey I had um I woke up and I just had
like this sore throat that just would
not go away right I didn't say anything
about it yeah um and then I go upstairs
and Sydney comes down and she's like oh
I think I got a sore throat I'm like
[ __ ] don't don't say that because if you
have something red that just means I'm
I'm not just like imagining this pain in
my throat right right so we're just like
I told Cindy no we're not gonna let this
ruin our [ __ ] holiday all right it's
it's like it's not real it's not real
you're literally literally just
[Music]
it was [ __ ] Christmas Eve right and
I'm like we're gonna open a bottle of
wine
we're gonna watch some [ __ ] horror
movies and uh we're gonna we're gonna
drink the pain away right it's all right
the alcohol will kill the disease this
is the worst medical advice in history
we are not MediCal experts do not listen
to any of this no yes this is like the
same level of logic as like you know
when you're one step away from getting
hypothermic you're like just take a shot
of the whiskey sure I don't know if I
and this is probably [ __ ] right I
feel like there is something in my head
right when I resign especially for
common colds and stuff like this when I
resign that in my head that I'm like I'm
sick that's when I become more sick yeah
in my head when I tell myself I'm not
sick this is a joke and I just keep
powering on I don't I feel like I get
less sick I don't know if this is
complete [ __ ] I feel like it is I
don't know why this happens scientists
explained why I feel this no Okay Okay
no Okay I totally get that though
because I mean with the stomach flu that
I had when I was starting to like
actually you know physically feel that I
was like oh here it comes in my head I
was like no I don't I don't I don't want
this it's fine yeah it's fine like yeah
I started to get like stomach cramps and
I started to get like a bit of a fever
and I was like no no it's fine it's it's
probably just like built up stress or
something no not right now not right now
but then the stomach flu is like what's
your Source
it's like oh really you don't have an
illness do you may I see your receipts
please no stomach flu holidays
what do you do you think okay do you
think the body is capable of doing
things that science can't really explain
sometimes because we hear we hear some
kind of these like stories every now and
then or like people who can do
incredible things it feels like one of
those alpha male conversations yeah
these guys in the jungle in uh in
Malaysia they are they actually found a
fruit that allows you to grow your dick
how do you become so Alpha that you can
control your body to the force
how do you unlock 100 of yourselves I
think there's like this is like a law of
attraction where if you get three dudes
on a podcast eventually they'll talk
about the human body and yeah I feel
like this is just a it's the rule of Joe
Rogan man this is a natural phenomenon
that happens and it is so [ __ ] dumb
because we're all [ __ ] stupid can we
coin this is The Joe Rogan no no I don't
give him a credit I just
names because they come up with dumb
[ __ ] like the the skips they're like the
cheetoskip
that's my favorite thing with like the
speed running like things it's like it's
like when when speedrunners come up with
like names of Tricks there's one or two
ways that you can name it the one way is
like to be like you name it after what
you do in it so it's like this one is
called the boulder skip because you use
a boulder to skip it and then the other
way is like this one is called the gym
sandwich because Jim was eating a
sandwich when he discovered it there's
only two ways you can name I watched uh
the latest summoning salt video that was
about the Star Wars Star Wars and I sat
there and I thought hmm I won't watch an
hour and a half film but I'll watch an
hour and a half video about Lego speed
runs and I thought there's something
wrong with me no not that that something
else videos aren't good but I'm like
what is going on in my brain where I'm
like it's like full produced The 100
million dollar movie I'm like no but
this Lego Star Wars speedrun
yeah this is what I want to watch I I
think it's I think there's just a
certain kind of commitment when it comes
to entertainment sometimes you want to
watch a highly produced like some like a
highly for sure produce piece of content
that you can really like invest yourself
in yeah
um but that takes a lot of like I I
think that takes a lot of emotional
commitment you know uh I agree uh and
that's why I think the Netflix logo is
too long I'm out
it's like five seconds
have you not done this think about it so
many times when that Netflix intro plays
I'm like no I'm actually good and I Tab
out I'm like
I think it gives me five seconds to like
realize I'm getting myself into
something and I'm like no hey does
anyone else do this I I hate how I know
exactly
well you've opened something on Netflix
and that Netflix thing plays the the
it's like it's literally like five
seconds but that five seconds gives me
five seconds to be like actually I don't
yeah it's like yeah it's the five second
window of are you sure you want to come
here yeah genuinely because then you
have like the again you have like
another 10 15 seconds of long [ __ ]
credits playing it's just it's more like
10 seconds because it's the five seconds
of the dude and then it usually is
followed by Netflix presents yeah it's
just long enough and it makes me it
makes me feel so serious the internet
has just hacked all of our minds because
this is yeah this they've just given us
pure ADHD at this point so the fact that
a 15 second intro of a logo can make us
rethink do I actually want to sit down
for this or do I just want to put on a
YouTube video which is immediately I
could have watched three YouTube shorts
at that time yeah like that's I have
found myself closing out of stuff a lot
more recently uh but I did watch
something that was kind of interesting
what's the show on Netflix called uh
Kaleidoscope I don't know if you've seen
this no no so the concept of the show is
that essentially uh there's Nine
episodes if I recall correctly and uh
every Netflix account will be presented
to them in a different order so you'll
get a different episode order depending
on also it's kind of like love death and
robots and robots yeah uh oh was it all
different for everyone yeah yeah the
episodes in that are all randomized oh I
didn't know that yeah but
um the one thing with this is that it is
just it's not like an anthology series
it's a it's a like a story oh progresses
but it's told out of order well it's
told whatever order you get given right
so it's a one connected story so it's
like a Tarantino yeah well so it's
really odd and um yeah yeah it's like
it's like it sounds it sounds okay it
sounds impossibly dumb yeah but the one
thing that I think they do is that I
think the last episode is always the
same I think okay
um so everything else this is a gimmick
it's a hundred percent it's a [ __ ]
gimmick it's a
it's called um harahi Suzumiya so
originally when Harry aired it was aired
in this there was there was this huge
debate when it aired right because it
was aired like like
um like the show out of order yeah where
every episode happened in a different
part of the timeline yeah and that was
the first season right
um and then everyone was just like oh my
God this is [ __ ] genius they're
letting us piece together the story by
telling it out of order we can piece
together the timeline ourselves yeah and
I'm [ __ ] convinced that they only did
that because the most interesting part
of the first Harry season were the first
six episodes and I think the producers
realized that because they realized holy
[ __ ] the last episode is is a [ __ ]
Christmas episode at least disappearance
it's basically a [ __ ] filler episode
we we can't end the season like this so
we have to like just piece The Ore piece
the episodes out of order to make it
seem interesting uh I mean it's I don't
know if it doesn't feel that way I was
very skeptical going into it because I
thought oh this is going to be Nine
episodes that feel completely
disconnected and then it's up to you to
put the pieces together yeah but it's
it's not really like that it was
actually pretty surprisingly not bad I
thought it was I again I was very
skeptical of the concept I was like this
[ __ ] dumb just tell me the story in
the order but depending on which order
you do get uh it can be a different
experience because essentially a lot of
the episodes cover like backstories and
certain information is kind of pieced
together or you're given certain like
you could figure something out way
sooner if you're given a certain episode
as opposed to something else this
literally just sounds like monogatari if
you didn't know the broadcasting order
if you just randomly picked seasons and
you're like oh okay I guess we're gonna
find out about this character that I
know nothing about it is kind of
interesting though I will say it's I
don't know if it's worth watching
because it did feel like after I got
halfway through it that okay it's like I
really did feel segmented yeah yeah but
I do think that if you've got certain
episodes it would feel like a completely
different as much as I realize it's like
a gimmick I do actually quite like like
storytelling methods like that
especially if like the actual root story
yeah so it's interesting enough so it's
about uh a bank heist yeah and basically
there's uh there's multiple characters
and there's certain episodes like an
episode where they they do the heist
there's an episode after the heist yeah
uh and so that you know there's a chance
that you could get the after the heist
episode first which might be confusing
because the characters aren't really
introduced properly where are there
other episodes that do introduce
characters better so it it's like that I
would say there probably is an order
that is probably best to watch it yeah
but you could get say like a Quentin
Tarantino experience if you had the
after Heist episode first yeah and then
you kind of piece everything together
well it does work the thing about how
you're describing it is that it to me
like I love the kind of Storytelling
method where it's not always presented
to you in chronological order but there
has to be some sort of intention with
that you know it needs to be done with
purpose like yeah the first example I
think of aside from Quentin Tarantino
it's like bacono right yeah Marco the
story is told in different time
perspectives and just not given to you
in chronological order but a lot of
thoughts from the you know creators was
given into what piece of information do
we allow the audience to see in order to
piece things together this just feels
like uh we have a story
um and we're just gonna randomize it and
uh let the audience figure it out and
I'm just like that's that's just [ __ ]
lazy okay it just sounds like a Vsauce
episode of like so the story starts at
chapter one or does it I think I think
it was probably just a case of hey we
have the show how do we secure Netflix
funding Let's Have a Gimmick they can
Market yeah to be fair it is interesting
like it's like it's kind of interesting
yeah it's impressive that you could have
all these episodes kind of be mixed and
it somehow still makes sense yeah is it
a good show uh I'd say seven out of ten
but the reviews are pretty positive for
it okay uh seven eight out of tens like
it's decent like it's a fun gimmick the
acting is kind of um some of the
characters act and you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah rather find you because they
have like Gus Gus from Breaking Bad this
is the main character and he's pretty
good because he's good in everything
yeah but some of the other actors you're
like what what are they playing a bad
guy again no he plays a good guy oh my
God oh my God good depending on who you
who you ask I suppose well you know
there's there is no way he can play
listen I'm I'm I'm of the mindset he's
playing a sauce again yeah Hey listen
remember we're following in the story
I'm like that's that's the good guy
straight up I don't care if he kills
everyone we're following him I I
sympathize with him yeah I got monkey
brain that's also definitely like a
trend or a gimmick recently as well
isn't it that Netflix is banking on with
a lot of their like fictional stories is
that like you're following the good guy
or is he really the good guy well I
think it's just made it like that
storytelling has become more popular big
shows like Breaking News genuinely I was
thinking about this the other day was
you still watching a lot of Netflix
right uh how much documentaries I was
like does Netflix still make good stuff
the journal consensus is no yeah because
I remember because like I realized
recently how just how little I watch
Netflix in comparison to you know what
are you how much I used to watch it you
used it used to be Netflix had this show
that I really really wanted to watch or
like a few shows and then you'd find
some random shows along the way yeah and
you and you know some random shows put
on the background and now it just seems
like every time I put on Netflix it's
just oh this is a background show and
it's it's never I never put on Netflix
to be like I'm going to commit to this
anymore
um I honestly just use Netflix to like
just watch like movies that I'm just
come out in the past where I'm just like
oh okay it's on Netflix I guess I'll
watch it while it's here but it's not
like something I'm like seeking out you
know it's not like I have to watch this
movie thank God it's on Netflix yeah I
mean I haven't watched the new glass uh
knives out yet but uh I heard that's
pretty good I I've watched it it's good
I I heard that it was all like every
story first one was really good it's
meant to be self-contained yeah right
um and yeah I mean how to find time it's
it's it was like a kind of like a murder
mystery who'd done it and then it didn't
blow my mind away or anything like that
you know it was it was it was a fun time
we watched on Christmas Eve I think
right and it was like for some reason
even though it was set in like the
middle of like a like a [ __ ] summer
like Mr Beast Private Island kind of I
got 10 people I'm an island to solve
America mystery one of them is going to
die you know you know what I remember
watching knives out and I was like this
just feels like a Mr Beast video that
they've thrifted for for like the
longest time it didn't make the YouTube
let's just give it let's just give it a
nail place
eventually killed Chandler and you have
to find out who did it
oh my God I mean yeah I mean I think
Netflix has really been struggling for a
while uh especially if you look at uh
the amount of shows they've canceled
yeah oh yeah the big meme is that they
just cancel every show that's remotely
interesting and good uh yeah they keep
pumping out 15 Adam Sandler movies
we definitely need those you know
apparently they do like in terms of
retention they're like one of the best
yeah people [ __ ] love Adam Sandler
movies to be fair I did watch Clique
while I was sick so well that's an older
one but I just knew about him they're
very easy to watch yeah what is like
what is it like a new Adam Sandler film
because I feel like I haven't heard of
an Adam Sandler film they're like 10
years because they're all just kind of
like direct to Netflix kind of meh yeah
it's like the equivalent of like
director DVD right right they don't
really get a cinema theater release have
you guys watched any of the recent ones
I watched one of them that was a murder
mystery funny enough like like a comedy
murder mystery just like a straight up
murder mystery comedy murder mystery
with like I think it was Jennifer
Aniston and that one was really bad but
I also didn't like I think he's done a
great job at making everyone know his
films suck but we'll still watch them
right because you're kind of like yeah I
mean he's harmless yeah it's like it's
like porridge you're like ah well I mean
I guess and I love what I don't hate it
hates me for two hours I think that's
what's happening today's episode is
sponsored by Honey the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone or computer
is there any better feeling than finding
a good deal I don't think so no exactly
well thanks to Honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the furry shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart boys imagine it you're shopping one
of your favorite websites when you get
to the checkout the honey button appears
and all you have to do is Click apply
coupons when a few seconds is honey
searches for coupons you can find on
that site and if Connie finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop oh
it's that easy it's that easy oh God
what did you save using honey well I've
been doing something a bit peculiar
recently I've been reading books [ __ ]
off like real books like real books and
honey has saved me five dollars buying
some of the best titles I could have
asked for did you know that honey
doesn't just work on desktops it works
on your iPhone too just activate on
Safari on your phone and you can save on
the gold no if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show so get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com trash taste
this episode is sponsored by raycon the
New Year gentleman is here and whether
you're making big changes or just
settling back into a consistent routine
chances are you could use some audio
accompaniment on your journey I know
that for me it's crucial he has been
listening to anything recently boys you
know I've been gone back to the gym and
man I have the best metal collection of
music that I listen to every time and
you know you want to blast that in your
ears right to get yourself pumping and
what better way than to get some high
quality earbuds like raycons for example
because raycons everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect inner
fit these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge raycons give you
eight hours of play time and a 32 hour
battery life some things I like about
the raycon earbuds is for example the
earbud tap functions where I don't have
to keep opening up my phone to go to the
next track I can just tap right there
what about the noise isolation I mean I
love it the last thing I want to hear is
the crappy music that plays at my local
gym so what are you waiting for go to
biracon.com trash taste today to get 15
off your raycon order that's byracon.com
trash takes to score 50 18 off by
raycon.com trash taste back to the
episode I also watched um
I wish you knew Avatar
oh the movie yeah I want to watch that
is it worth it how was it long yeah
it's like three and a half hours long
it's it's so long yeah it doesn't feel
long yes yes I fell asleep uh
but I woke up and I felt like I didn't
miss anything so that's also I heard
it's just the same story as the first
movie but just it's underwater now it's
the water people oh man the next movie
is the fire people so he's one element
away from a lawsuit he's got to be
careful yeah the fourth one I heard
they've already filmed it I I he can't
be doing all four elements I mean no he
I think he has filmed all of them yes
yes but if he can't do all four elements
surely I mean that's and apparently the
Fire Nation are like the bad people in
this one too I feel like come on and
then eventually Jake Sully is gonna have
a [ __ ] arrow on his head and start
floating around also listen I I watched
Avatar and I watched it in this oh [ __ ]
in Canada
um I watched it in this weird
um I've never seen this before it's like
some kind of like the main screen and
then the walls have a projector where it
extends the screen so like there's more
stuff like a curved screen no no no like
a wall yeah and then the two side walls
are projected and there's just more off
of the screen I don't know what this is
called can we google this what yeah like
an old like an ultra wide screen no it's
not a screen it's literally just the
walls but they're like projecting like
more of the screen uh I must imagine
like this like this is the set of trash
taste right yeah this is the screen what
you'd normally see and then there's just
like all of this that you don't see
right they've just projected that on the
walls oh it's weird it's not like zoomed
in or anything it's like so is this
stuff happening on the sides
like background stuff oh so it's kind of
like it's kind of like adding to these I
think he's just trying to immerse you it
was really [ __ ] right I don't think it's
very weird like it's like you go from
this like 800k display to like Blurry
wall like it's kind of it's kind of a
shooting projection yeah it's kind of
[ __ ] I really like it I I heard see
because I haven't seen it yet but I've
heard a lot of people talking about it
and like kind of giving their like
criticisms and stuff like that well for
one it's like too long um and two I
heard that like they shot it at a
different frame rate right I don't know
I think apparently the second can you
look this up but like apparently from
whatever from a couple of my friends
yeah oh so Joey
according to my gamer friends they were
saying that like apparently now this one
instead of the standard cinema Standard
24 frames it's done in like 49 frames or
something but 48 so some Cinemas that
don't support the 48 frames it just
makes the movie look like [ __ ] right and
it's kind of and it's kind of like again
like please confirm this but like yeah
it is right so it's like so if you go to
a cinema that supports 48 frames then it
doesn't make it any better because it
kind of is the same vibe in my head it's
kind of the same Vibe as like you know
watching like 60 frames per second anime
this looks a little like okay it's like
a little too smooth no no there there is
a difference between 60 frames per
second anime yeah and a movie that was
intentionally shot at a certain frame
rate right because 60 frame of 60 frames
per second anime isn't actually 60
frames per second anime it's at 24
frames per second but someone's put it
through a [ __ ] After Effects filter
yeah to interpolate the frames so it
looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] please stop
doing that to animation oh my God it's
like my biggest [ __ ] stuff all the
time it has not died really I haven't
seen it in a while okay every time I
want to like search up a cool anime
fight or like an anime opening on
YouTube the 4K 60fps the top results is
never actually the original [ __ ] seed
it's always interpolated and I'm not
saying like all interpolation looks bad
there are some like amvs and there are
some edits that can make really good use
of the interpolation effect but you
can't just put an entire [ __ ] scene
through that and think that it's all
going to translate well it just ruins
the entire scene to me and it just it
it's all right yeah even though I guess
like the concept or like you know the
the transition from the original source
is different like it's kind of from what
I heard from a couple of my friends it's
kind of that same feeling of like
because you're so used to watching it in
24 frames like you know like you know
cinematic films when you watch it at
Double the frame rate it's like oh it's
like the first time you watch 60 frames
per second YouTube is just like oh this
is really smooth to the point where it's
kind of uncomfortable yeah and like I
don't know I don't know what James
Cameron's in you know like idea for that
was he's obviously trying to like push
Cinema in different ways right but it's
like
I don't know if that was the right move
frames yeah it's like I don't have more
frames I think if that's true I don't
think that's the first film that's done
that because I'm sure it's not but like
at the same time it's like was it Hobbit
or something that also did the same
thing that like filmed at a higher frame
rate and people there was this
disconnect where it like some of the
feedback that was given was people who
weren't just just weren't used to seeing
films in a higher frame rate did you
notice the difference when you watched
the Avatar movie uh no
um I don't think so it just looked like
a standard 24. yeah man bro it was it
was good
um I just wish it wasn't that long it
was really really long all right
um it's just was it a good film I would
say yes but I don't think it's a great
episode I've never seen someone that's
so confused about because like
experience with the film on one hand I'm
like you know I fell asleep for like 20
30 minutes at one point and I felt like
I missed nothing when I woke up I felt
like I knew exactly what what I'd kind
of missed well for one falling asleep in
a film is never never I mean it was just
like they just can't fall asleep for
like a fifth of the film being like I
think it was a good film no I think like
when I was awake and like technically
speaking like it's a [ __ ] Master
Class like it looks insane yeah it is
stunning yeah but also it you know I
mean Avatar won I do watch Avatar one
yeah well you've seen Avatar one and I
kind of felt that it didn't really
expand upon it in a way that I was kind
of hoping
um well Avatar one was never about like
the storyline yeah Avatar one is just
Pocahontas in space right but like how
do you how do you make then a sequel to
a story that wasn't even that really
impactful did you like Avatar one I
liked Avatar one I thought as a as it
was it wasn't like crazy long yeah I did
what it needed to do it told the story
and at the time it was like technically
groundbreaking it was good yeah I think
what made Avatar one entertain painting
at least for me at the time was the fact
that compared to other yeah but compared
to other like film you know cinematic
like big cinematic films at the time I
think its strongest point was definitely
just like how insane like the the CG was
right oh like the the visual it's it's
even visual elements right yeah but like
I feel now I think the reason why people
aren't talking about it as much with the
second film is because now there's a lot
of like you know like MCU films and like
big cinematic films that uh probably at
the same quality if not you know a
similar quality to what Avatar 2 might
have again this come from someone who
hasn't seen the film just I mean how to
technically looks way better than any of
any MCD films did it did it like give
you okay here's the thing about Avatar
one which I'll never forget
um even though I've forgotten like I've
forgotten everything I've forgotten like
most of like the story and characters
yeah it's what I'm is what I was trying
to say but I will never forget the
experience of watching Avatar one for
the first I'm in cinemas because they
[ __ ] I remember being blown away by the
experience and the visual effects yeah
and that's that that feeling has still
never been eclipsed in like Cinemas for
me uh even watching like endgame or
stuff like that like it's never eclipsed
the first time seeing Avatar one in
cinemas being like holy [ __ ] CGI and
films can look this good yeah it is it
is like a step up again yeah you think
you're like how could it look better
than the first was it what was it again
it was like it's the underwater CG right
it's like they're selling there's a lot
of like I mean there's the whole [ __ ]
film's water right and it's it's cool I
just think the problem is I just like um
because obviously if you remember the
first film it was Jake Sully was the
main character yeah
um I dude man something I'm racist
against Blue people but dude I I had
such a hard time in the start of the
movie figuring out who the [ __ ] was who
um I guess because it's like it's it's
all all these blue people look the
[ __ ] same like all these because it's
the whole movie is basically from the
perspective of like avatars yeah yeah
and the navi yeah the navi and you just
kind of like for a while you're like I
don't [ __ ] care like like I don't
care about Jake Sully's kids I like and
then I I just I think that was the
problem is that we hadn't obviously
because it's been so long and the story
is like many many years in the future
you introduce these characters you've
never met I don't [ __ ] particularly
like the kids that much and I just kind
of thought God damn man can I just like
can we just do something else I just
have like a different character I don't
remember one thing I kept seeing on like
Tick Tock especially is just like these
like weird fan cams for like Jake Sully
and Avatar too because he's like because
unlike in the first film in the second
film he's like a dad now yeah right and
he's like and there's like this like
weird group of people on Tick Tock that
I've seen of like people making fan cams
of Jake Sully as being like kind of like
a dilf material yeah and they're just
like I saw this one of like this girl
freaking out because in one scene I
guess in Avatar too Jake Sully goes like
what's up baby girl
well I just people who are like info
like delf side of things just like oh my
God he's so hot and I'm like we
definitely didn't have that in Avatar
BTS I sleep now Jake Sully Sully as a
deal
they did this really one really cool
thing where uh Jake Sully is uh so
before this happens in the film when
they're talking about vehicle subtitles
and then one scene he goes like oh yeah
it's like English to me now because he's
like talks about how he became so native
yeah yeah and as he says that we start
hearing the native language in English
and the rest of the film it's all in
English when they speak in like that oh
is that like cool transition I thought
that was pretty cool that's a really
cool way of handling how you have this
language and kind of getting over it and
making it I guess people don't want to
because otherwise the whole movie would
be Savvy subtitles I guess people don't
want to sit through three and a half
hours of subtitles oh dog yeah man I
could not sit through that yeah
we can never do that who would want to
do that
I guess just when it's a made-up
language you're like why just just put
it in a [ __ ] language yeah I guess I
get it you want to build the world up
but it's like it's like three hours
you're like yeah that's that's a bit too
much is the World building that am I
Really Gonna Be that did the visuals
blow you away as much as seeing Avatar
one for the first time I mean I was so
young when I watched Avatar one I can't
yeah I don't really remember I mean I I
you know when I was sitting there
watching it I was very impressed I'll
say that much like you can't not notice
how insane it looks yeah yeah
um I mean even just watching the
trailers it's like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah and
again it's one of those movies that if
you haven't I'd recommend going checking
out at theaters yeah okay because
because like it'd be a shame to watch it
at home yeah I mean from the trailers
alone it looks insane but I don't know
if it's me getting old or if it's just
technology reaching kind of like it's
April looks really good in general
nowadays yeah yeah because because it's
similar to what's going on with like
video gaming right now right where I
remember you know growing up playing
like the Super Nintendo and then
scanning an N64 for the first time and
seeing that jump from 2D to 3D it was
[ __ ] insane yeah it blew my mind kids
today will never be able to feel that
and then like going from like Mario 64
to seeing like the visual Improvement
into Mario Sunshine yeah that was like
[ __ ] insane and yeah and then like
and now you can see Mario's Paws it's
like technology improves I'm like I'm
looking at let's say uh I remember
playing the original Last of Us I know I
see like the remaster and I'm like
What's the what's what's the difference
I don't I don't I don't see it and I'm I
look at Avatar too just the trailers I
haven't seen the film I look at Avatar
too and I'm like this looks fantastic
but I look at Avatar one and I'm like
this still looks fantastic right and I
don't know if I'll ever get that same
wow moment like how much better could we
get to the point where it actually makes
a like a discernible difference
exactly I mean I was someone Blown Away
by you know Masterpiece that hentai that
was definitely more visually impressive
speaking of which the third one's coming
out this month and I'm very oh really um
they clear they bring it back they're
bringing it back Avatar too I sleep
in my calendar
I've called up Kleenex I'm like send it
all send everything
bring in the blue light
I I mean let's
let's find I think uh I'm I don't know
how Avatar three and four are gonna be
interesting enough to keep everyone yeah
because I heard that Avatar 2 didn't
really do that great box office wise I I
could be compared to Avatar one or just
in general uh in general like in the
village yeah you need to you know make a
lot more money in cinema today to make
it more viable for sure yeah and
especially with the amount of money and
time he sunk into it yeah I just I
because I feel bad for the guy if he if
he wouldn't be able to like finish the
vision he had for it because I do want
to see how it ends still like I think
it's a it's a cool enough world where uh
and he's he's such a good filmmaker
James Cameron in general where I want to
see where it goes uh I just worry that
it didn't do well enough and if the
third one doesn't do well yeah like what
you know is he gonna is he gonna be like
fine I'll do it myself I'll bankroll it
like like what's gonna because he he's a
crazy guy yeah he is a [ __ ] insane
guy
um especially when it comes to the art
filmmaking as well um he definitely
pushes the boundary sure um one thing
that really surprised me about Avatar
too was how little I heard about it
before it actually came out I didn't
yeah I didn't I didn't know it was out
until it came out you know normally I
remember Avatar one came out came out
when that came out it was this [ __ ]
hyped thing this hyped movie that
completely revolutionized digital
technology in films and it did at the
time you know it was also like that kind
of kicked off like what a very big wave
of 3D yeah that's why we have 3D cinemas
still stuck with us the garbage yeah
yeah but like I I heard nothing about
Avatar 2 before and I don't know if it
was it's just me not being as involved
in like the film industry or anything
like that or like even less but even
still it was like I wasn't necessarily
in that Community when Avatar one came
out but it was like inescapable like
everyone was talking about that film
like so much so to the point where
everyone was like they made it like
their job to just go and watch it and
you know regardless of whether you
enjoyed it or not but this one it's like
yeah I don't know maybe it's because
like the the the the environment of like
you know movies being promoted and stuff
like that has changed over the years
since Avatar one came out but like yeah
same thing it's like I found out about
the trailer because I saw it on YouTube
and I'm like oh this trailer came out a
week ago and I hadn't heard about it
yeah like I knew it was coming but I
didn't know when it was coming I didn't
even know look I I had heard that in the
Woodworks that there was like an Avatar
2 being made yeah and then my next my
next news about Avatar 2 is that it's
out I was like what what this was in
production this entire time well I like
I had more information about [ __ ]
Dune coming out before then you know I
think people were pretty excited about
it um it was weird he was really
scattered online it wasn't like this one
big push the marketing wasn't crazy for
it either yeah um I think that was
probably because they were just banking
off the fact that it's like everyone's
seen Avatar yeah maybe I don't know I
wonder what it was I I either way I mean
I I hope it does well enough to to come
back for a third and fourth I hopefully
won't fall asleep next time I just think
it was too damn long it was too damn
long fell asleep seven hours seven eight
hours
I didn't okay too fair that day I was
very tired and I felt like I would have
fallen asleep in most movies unless they
were like insane all right that day
particularly it just hurt Avatar that it
was just kind of like hey
that's just like a lot going on and in
the middle my God does the film feel so
[ __ ] slow right because you know the
start's kind of really engaging is a lot
happening and in the end there's this
giant like you know [ __ ] singing the
battle that goes on for like 40 50
minutes of course Jesus and it's a
really impressive and cool but even that
felt like hey come on can we like can we
yeah
it felt like I've shown him because like
something would happen and then it'd be
defeated and then of course there's
another like but he's getting back up or
right oh but this guy's coming back and
it's like what the [ __ ] man I like to
call it the nanny moments yeah yeah just
like what talking about don't not
wanting to commit like entertainment
because like I I wanted to watch Avatar
too because like I said it looks
beautiful but yeah the thought of having
to go to the cinema and sit down for
like two and a half two and a half three
hours I'm like maybe I'll do it tomorrow
Tomorrow Comes
ah maybe maybe like the day after you
know I'll I'll get some time and then I
know if I don't watch Avatar 2 in
cinemas I'm not gonna watch it on like
on the small screen yes there's no point
there's no point in my mind so the
clock's ticking
how much longer is it out it was like a
week or two I can't imagine it'd be too
much oh [ __ ] all right I gotta make some
time then yeah watch it it's definitely
an experience it is an experience there
are a lot of things like getting your
balls castrated it's brilliant
experience I was asleep for 30 minutes
I imagine her stomach flu isn't
experiences that was an experience for
sure I was asleep for most of that and
that was like a two out of ten so I
might like Avatar I enjoy it Avatar too
it's kind of like getting stomach flu
sleep through most of them and then you
just you know it's a majority of it is
painful and you sleep through some of it
because I feel well rested for the year
coming up oh my God yeah because I mean
before this episode we were you know
because you know this is our first day
back in the office
um and so we obviously had to figure out
what our schedules were for this year
and uh
just tldr it's [ __ ]
like this but which is good you know
we're keeping ourselves busy
um but um yeah lots of cool things lots
of exciting things coming up which we
can probably show you how's Canada yeah
how's Canada Canada's fun Canada's chill
I mean I you know we went skiing in so
much in Whistler right yeah in Vancouver
yeah as every good white person does uh
on vacation I went skiing I'm now
kidding uh that was good it's fine uh
it's just like busy it's a very popular
place to go yeah I guess I know have you
ever been skiing uh it's fine it's fun I
like it it's fun yeah trying to think
about how to describe it like it was
very standard because I mean I I wasn't
really going well the question what was
the better experience skiing or Avatar
series selling this probably skiing okay
good selling this experience uh Conor's
just like yes
one of my brothers works out there and
uh I just wanted to spend time with my
family because I haven't seen my older
brother in like five years damn and then
spent Christmas with my whole family
together in like five years so I was
like okay yeah sure when they wanted to
go out to Canada yeah sure even though
I've spent most of this goddamn year in
North America yeah I'm like sure let's
go to Canada let's go again yeah yeah
like kind of the shell kind of this fun
uh Canada's like a really nice place
everyone's nice uh it was just like when
I arrived in Vancouver it was like a
crazy snowstorm and so like yeah it was
insane yeah Aki's uh Aki's flight got
delayed a day because apparently like
all of like the North and like East
Coast were just having these like
horrible like blizzards I think when I
flew in it was like uh at least half the
flights to Vancouver have been like
canceled yeah uh but for me I was like
dude like nothing like yeah nothing got
to the airport I was like damn it's dead
no one's here and I was like I say weave
through it all it's crazy I was super
super easy oh man Canadian immigration
people are so much more chill than
American ones that's for sure they are
they're like so what you do and I'm like
skiing they're like have a great have a
good one and I was like oh this is right
meanwhile us would be like where exactly
are you staying what's your middle name
what's your family what's your mom's
maiden name like what's the like
circumference of your ball sack we need
to know tell me your entire family tree
right now give me a review of Avatar 2
right now I think because when I went
with uh when I went to the US in
December with Pete I think Pete try to
crack a few jokes Pete's American yeah
he was cracking a few jokes the
immigration people and they were just
like no don't but he's American it's
like not not right now I'm sorry I have
to stop you but shut the [ __ ] up
I mean Kevin is nice and Canada's just
chill I mean I literally just all I did
was maybe like okay one day I might go
skiing and then my family and then yeah
actually I would just do nothing and
just chill I've actually never been to
that side of Canada I've never been to
the Vancouver side like I've I've like
gone like you know uh laid over and
stuff like that in Vegas over airport
but like I've never been outside I've
heard Vancouver is a very nice city it
feels like Seattle but more Canadian
right it's very like probably because it
is it's very geographically very close
yeah but it had similar Vibes to uh
Seattle I think I prefer the uh east
coast of Canada
also into like New Brunswick before and
that was kind of more chill felt I feel
like Vancouver doesn't feel very
stereotypically Canadian right in a
sense just feels like a more like a
North American city with a Sprinkle of
Canada a little sprinkle of Canada
sprinkler Canada uh but it was fine I
mean I didn't spend that much uh time in
Vancouver actually I dude I there's I
when we're looking at places to eat it
was like all Japanese and Korean and
Chinese restaurants really yeah because
I think there's a giant Asian population
yeah
there's a giant Asian population massive
massive and yeah dude the lines for all
the ramen shops were insane like loads
did you eat anything wrong yeah I had I
had no it was um
um
all the ramen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
better chain they have one in that group
they had one in Vancouver and I was like
because that's where my family and they
were like we'd like to try it and I was
like all right well I'm flying back to
Japan tomorrow but I I'll never say no
to some Ramen and it seemed like it was
like I mean it was a Japanese chain so I
thought that's pretty legit yeah it was
pretty good I'd say it was probably just
as good as most Japanese ramen honestly
okay I think a lot of people like to
pretend that Ramen is some kind of Godly
thing here but honestly like I feel like
no it's it's it's literally junk food
yeah it's it's really like if you have
the ingredients it's kind of hard to
[ __ ] it up it's like the cheapest meal
you can get here yeah it's like yeah
sure there are some amazing ones in
Japan but like the bog standard Ramen
you get in Japan like it isn't
especially people making out to be yeah
um and so yeah it was fun it was good
and all the staff spoke Japanese so I
was like I was like me me I mean I got
this i got this I think they were like
what the [ __ ] when I started speaking
yeah when you boss it up
I'll take Ramen
they were pretty chill about it they
just didn't even bet an eye but I was
like I wouldn't Japanese my family like
whoa It's almost like you've been living
in Japan
you could do that and I was like well
yeah I mean I guess I can order food
is like yo he's fluent in Japanese
how'd you say this in Japanese how'd you
say that in Japanese I was I was there
and I was like I swear I was like
Canadian Matt Stone he'd come in
opposite me bro this guy ordered three
Romans to himself and ate them what yeah
it was insane like like stand full bowls
of ramen I was like I was eating my rum
and I was like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was getting so distracted by this guy
I felt bad I was like staring at him
because I was like how is that was this
guy I'm surprised your competitiveness
didn't kick in Billy us
I realized I was struggling to eat my
large-sized Ramen I I regretted getting
the lodge but it's decent yeah I mean
Canadian food is um
just an American food kind of they don't
know I mean I guess on that side of
America right yes very Americanized
stuff I mean I had poutine obviously I
mean I even though poutine meets the
hype because oh [ __ ] no we have that in
the UK it's literally called chips
cheese and gravy yeah pretend like it's
different but it's literally not we came
before you don't [ __ ] try and take
ourselves you can you can put a name on
it we literally had that we've always
had that in the UK it's it's it's just
because it has like a [ __ ] French
name there it sounds like yeah a Cuisine
yeah every single chip shop in like the
north UK does this and and it tastes no
different I don't care what they say it
literally tastes but there's one issue
with that you have to go to the north
yeah yeah
thank you for seeing you Joey thank you
for using it no if you care all right I
will say that in occasional restaurants
you can get like fancier versions
they're pretty good yeah we had a fancy
ones when we were in Toronto
good snack foods that's fine I'm not
gonna be like hey dog get in here you
gotta try this like yeah one but it felt
like it was okay this is uh this is like
junk food it's it's like a comfort junk
food yeah and you've just prettied it up
a bit you know I just you know it's it's
like serving bangers and mash or
something and you know it's it's there's
only so much you can do with like
bangers and match right but at the end
of the day it's just some sausages a bit
of gravy and some uh some [ __ ] um
maybe that's what you guys need to start
doing instead of calling it something
like unattractive like bangers and mash
give it like a fancy name we need some
more [ __ ] I don't know what you're
talking about that's [ __ ] hot I don't
know man we need some more [ __ ]
French names man ever done the French
name something it just automatically
sounds it's called like
it's like oh [ __ ] you can charge ten
times the amount exactly [ __ ] thing
big brain like why are we calling it
like [ __ ] milk call it like
liquidity it's like [ __ ] 15 or
something obviously we're full in French
as you can tell
yeah exactly there's a reason why they
call it omelette do formage instead of
cheese omelette yeah you know it's just
like it just sounds a little fancy it's
like oh okay all right fancy boy right
speaking a whole nother language God
damn all right all right you know what
memes I'm really glad I made a comeback
Zoolander memes
yeah they're like they're back in man
it's so good that's so good that's so
funny that's a movie I've won a free
watching that's been my highlight of the
end of 2022 yeah
I recommended and they're all bangers
they're all so good that's bangers and
mash right
all I did all uh you know because I was
with my family and obviously my family
just want to have drinks every night so
yeah I came back and I was like please
no more drinks no well that's just like
every holiday in England oh for sure I'm
not sure about America but uh you just
eat a [ __ ] on and you drink a [ __ ] ton
um and that's basically what I did for
my holiday I gained a lot of weight that
I'm I'm back on that [ __ ] salad diet
guys I see on the contrary I lost a lot
of weight because I was drinking nothing
but picar sweat for five years
I wanted to lose the weight but I was
like not like this this is probably the
worst way to do it
I always wondered when I'm like when you
get to the stream like is that is it
weird that they know our health results
I'm like because I I told my chat too
I'm like whatever I mean I did a video
last year yeah I wondered I'm like is it
weird that we're making content out of
this maybe a little weird maybe a little
weird but yeah sure sure it was better
than last year it was it was actually
wow
it's working I I actually improved and
like everything I almost everything I
got to be in was like moved up to an A
and I remember last year I got like a C3
for my urine which oh [ __ ] that's right
I don't know what the [ __ ] I did I was
like pissing wrong uh this year got
upgraded to an A so I'm like okay
I haven't got my results back but uh
mine has been the exact same for the
past three years yeah mine's probably
gonna be the same like Connor you're the
perfect specimen of a human being but
but what's going on with that
cholesterol we could have sort that out
it was a little lower this year though
but again like all this [ __ ] means
nothing it's like they're like oh this
is what your HG slash L is I'm like can
you can you [ __ ] tell me what that
means also not to mention it's kind of
unfair for like people like us because
the they base that ranking mostly on
like the Japanese average yeah dude when
they measure my waist I'm like bro I got
a cake down there what are you like of
course it's not gonna be like yeah I'm
gonna come back fat yeah like because I
remember last year they were like oh
your uh your waistline is a little bit
wider than uh you know average and I'm
like no I'm just bigger than the average
Japanese person though okay is that what
you want to say just gonna be fat no
it's it's just say it yeah it's it's
called natural insulation and it's great
in the winter I'm carb loading okay
stocking up for the winter yeah I
remember when I when I was I think I got
that Health checkup uh in December dude
I remember I felt so I I was like this
the one person who stood at the most I
walked in wearing my drip jacket and I
just and I just sat down in this thing
between like 20 other Japanese
businessmen in suits and I'm just there
in my grip jacket yeah like number 22
I'm like it's me
just walking through these dudes and
they were just like are you here for the
health check I'm like
saw this
results just as alpha male
dude I gold splitted the circuit this
year though I went through everything so
goddamn oh yeah there's like nobody
there yeah so I just went through
everything like I was in I had done like
a it's crazy right Japan you do like you
do an x-ray you do a blood pressure you
do uh wait and height test you do uh
blooded
um uh injection no uh [ __ ] uh blood
sample yeah uh hearing listening test
the doctor consultation uh waste and
kind of I guess waste and then uh and
then they do like the heart they do yeah
things on your heart and they test it
all that in like 15 to 20 minutes like
that I actually like I don't know maybe
they changed it up on the day that I did
it but like they did it in like a
completely different order so I so
normally it's like the X-ray first right
yeah I did the cardio thing first I
guess it depends on like yeah so I was
like oh are we is this like a new speed
run straight like are we it's crazy are
we doing a cardio skip yes you're legit
like a cattle it's so impressive how
good they are yeah they're just like
boom boom boom boom you're right I don't
mind being treated like a cattle yeah
that's great give me some grass dog
I'm down like do they take like [ __ ]
five to six of bottles of blood when
they take your blood as well
no no they do like two or three what I'm
looking I'm like it's like one or two
tops for me no no they they take at
least three really yeah but they do it
so fast that you don't even notice
because they do it mid conversation
they're like oh does it hurt
yeah and then they've replaced it with a
new vial before me yeah because I I like
I think we've talked about this before
but I can't look when they're taking the
blood
um so then you know I'm having this
conversation with the nurse or whatever
who's obviously trying to keep my mind
off it and then I look back and there's
like a basket full of just like my
[ __ ] blood of like five vials I don't
know if you hit 30 the the like they
make you do more tests but I'm like
Jesus Christ that was in my body the
lady's like this is my Personal
Collection
I've been meaning to test some fine
timeline
oh my God yeah but I mean the health is
all it's a good way to keep you on your
keep you on your toes yeah if you get to
I think 40 you have to do a mandatory
colonoscopy yeah yeah this isn't that
[ __ ] wild yeah that that seems like
I'm just not gonna make it a 40. I'm
chill I'm not I'm quitting I'm out see
it's a 39 you're like I'm out I
understand why we're doing it and I
understand the risks of not having a
colonoscopy and I'm good with that do
they are nests the size you though no no
not in Japan no in Japan there's a lot
of common procedures in the US where you
would get anesthesia yeah you don't in
Japan so so what you just awake while
they shove a camera up your ass yeah
[Music]
guaranteed there's some 40 year old
salary man that's just like it's time
for my yearly Health checkup oh boys I
couldn't sleep last night because I was
so excited
they go
like that when you miss it oh yeah oh my
God so there's no way I I they must have
it like yeah
yeah they just like play like a thing
like a recording of a woman it's
concerning though if you look up like uh
or ask people who've had certain
surgeries in Japan and if you have the
exact same surgery in like the us or
Europe you you would you would have some
kind of pain medicine in Japan it's only
like no yeah for certain things that you
would in other countries they're trying
to bring super [ __ ] concerning you're
like I would like to not feel this
please yeah it's like it's the only time
where Japan is like you're an alpha male
all right you can take it it's strange
yes obviously you don't want to use
super strong painkills but you don't
have to but there's some some situation
you're like please I beg of thee please
give me something I don't want to feel
this yeah I am begging you like I
literally don't have an option to not do
this it's mandatory and also I guess uh
Japan doesn't you know the over the
counter pain medicines also super weak
which is probably a better thing uh
because in America the stuff you can get
is pretty [ __ ] strong yeah I think
they do that mostly I think I remember
reading it up I think they did that
mostly because says it's for the older
generation who like you know their body
can't take as much stronger medicine but
still it's like because I remember you
know I had to buy some pain medicine
when I had the stomach flu right and I
and I went to the pharmacy to get some
over the counter and I was like giving
your strongest [ __ ] I am dying right now
and she was like all right here you go
and I looked at the packet and it was
like take three times a day uh one time
take seven tablets and I'm like
I'm just like [ __ ] chowing down on my
tablets
uh the first time I got sick in Japan
yeah uh because you know I I remember
that that one time uh we had karaoke
together and like we all got ill or
something like that
yeah I remember we had like had it was a
10-day trip and had one day of karaoke
and uh with Joey and then the rest of
the trip was just me being ill in bed
with Sydney in my Airbnb and that was my
trip to Japan but I remember like good
times I thought for how expensive the
over-the-counter medicine was because
you can get like paracetamol lemsip you
know Tylenol in England and America yeah
pretty cheap uh and here I remember like
this one this one week I spent like a
hundred bucks at least for just like a
week's worth of over-the-counter
medicine and it was like weakest [ __ ] it
it did nothing give me the real [ __ ]
yeah give me the real [ __ ] I'm ready doc
but but I think that's the thing it's
like I don't know if it's like a tactic
or whatever but like I think that's why
a lot of Japanese people just don't even
bother going to the over-the-counter
stuff they just go see a doctor to get
like the actual proper stuff because
again like when I had the flu and like
the pain medicine like the seven [ __ ]
the 21 tablets a day was just like not
working for me I was like yeah all right
doc I I like this shit's not working for
me give me the actual good stuff yeah uh
and he gave me just one week give me the
good stuff and he gave me one which was
just like one tablet three times a day
and that worked a million times better
than the over-the-counter stuff and it
and it cost less yeah and I was like
what the [ __ ] am I doing buying this
over the counter [ __ ] that doesn't work
it's over the counter [ __ ] you you pay
like 20 bucks for one box and it lasts
you like a day because you're taking
five pills oh like they they recommend
like before and after uh before every
meal take five tablets I'm like there's
only [ __ ] ten tablets in this box
what are you talking about you know that
you know that like stereotype of like
you know like old folks homes where you
know they have like the tablets thing
what what's it like in Japan it's just
like here's here's your cereal bowl of
tablets today man yeah
I can't read this [ __ ] anyway so I don't
even know so I just don't bother and I'm
like I'm dying I'm like it's fine I'll
be fine I remember after like my first
few months of living in Japan uh the
next time I went back to England I'm
like Mom just let me go to Tesco's let
me stock up on all of the [ __ ] let me
stock up on all of the over-the-counter
medicines and I I remember I didn't
realize that there was a limit to how
much like limb sip you can oh yeah I
mean you just have to be really careful
because some over-the-counter stuff in
the US and the UK uh most certainly
cannot bring into Japan oh yeah you're
getting a lot of trouble if you do yeah
um so please before you bring any
medicine into Japan or any country you
just make sure that you're allowed to
yeah uh generally really weak
over-the-counter stuff is normally fine
yeah yeah because because I I wanted to
stock up on like paracetamol and Tylenol
yeah stuff like that well paracetamol is
a generic drug and you can do that in
Japan as well you can get that in Japan
but it's it doesn't work it does
yeah yeah it's uh it was just like a lot
weaker and a lot more expensive so I was
like [ __ ] it I'll just like buy uh buy
some blem soup buy some paracetamol to
bring into the country so I have like
this medicine box in my home that I can
always rely on uh and I remember going
to the co-op to buy like to buy like all
of these different boxes of paracetamol
and they're like what what are you uh
what are you doing here you like are you
like dealing to kids or something what's
going on here
like no sir you don't understand I'm
just going to Japan
I'm sure that helped clear it up it's
like oh of course all right okay I think
like a generic box because of passion
smallest like it's like in in like US
Dollars it's like 50 cents 40 cents
really super cheap damn that's really
cheap it's generic like you can get it
anywhere holy [ __ ] and a lot of stores
sell it in Japan it's like [ __ ] 15
bucks yeah super expensive it's
ridiculous but a bowl of ramen took five
yeah so you can have five bowls of ramen
or we cash painkillers yeah like
paracetamol in in Japanese in Japanese
or it's like another difficult vitamin
or something or something something like
that yeah it's [ __ ] cold all right we
are not MediCal experts please don't
listen to any of our medical advice and
please make sure that you ask a
professional before you're Consulting
yeah advice ask a doctor which we are
not honestly like my like like genuinely
my my advice of like if you're coming to
Japan and you get sick is that like well
obviously first get like you know travel
insurance and [ __ ] and just like go see
a dog because like for one you're gonna
get what you need and also for in a lot
of ways it is cheaper and just better in
my opinion and also like a lot of those
these like you know General
Practitioners like they don't take that
much time out of your day like when I
went to go to the hospital it literally
took me like 20 minutes yeah the one
thing that is good about trying is they
are pretty quick yeah you don't really
sit around like in the UK you can be
sitting there for a long time waiting
it's pretty sure yeah I was only around
for like 20 minutes and like the doctor
checked me out for like you know a
couple of minutes and was just like yep
here's these are drugs it's either good
or bad
it's like hey dog you're fine [ __ ] off
yeah uh sure drugs drugs drugs
I love drugs so I went to an art
exhibition the other day
you hate parks and now you thought not
exhibition's better it was like it was
like okay there's different types of
artix yeah okay okay there's the
pretentious kinds
finish that sentence show there's The
Pretender okay and the ones I like
there's the pretentious kinds and then
there's like the fun interactive kinds
okay I went to the fun interactive okay
good which one what are the pretentious
kinds you know the ones that are just
like the like look I'm gonna call them
out a lot of the Contemporary Arts
museums around the world that I've been
to are just like a little bit to like
you know this is odd I have nailed a
banana to the wall and I've called it
actually duct tape but honestly whatever
I would argue that they're all like that
though
um some of them are just more fun
actually I think I think older art
museums are pretty stunning yeah those
ones those ones up close yeah for sure
that's [ __ ] stuff yeah yeah yeah
um yeah I mean like we went to this I
can't remember the name it was like team
Labs or something like oh yeah yeah yeah
oh you went to team I went to team it's
like yeah that is like I am a tourist in
Japan yeah yeah every single article
about well uh places to go in Japan has
teams has teammates I don't know if
they've dominated the like tourism
you've been obviously right yeah I've
never been you never no I mean I've been
like two or three times yeah because
like the only reason I was I was there
because like we were in the area and we
got like a like an hour or two to kill I
was like what's in the area oh team
lapse let's let's go check it out and
it's it's weird right because it was
like the whole thing's about team Labs
is that there's it's this kind of like
interactive kind of our exhibition where
they have different pieces that most of
them you can interact with right for
Instagram huh for Instagram it is an
Instagram it is like it's literally
nobody nobody there actually cares about
the art I'll say that yeah everyone
there cares about getting a cool [ __ ]
problem no one no one goes into a team
Labs room and goes I love the way that
the colors are representing our internal
story no they're just like all right
where is the prettiest background for my
next Instagram yeah I I know this
because I was the only one actually
[ __ ] reading the text with every
exhibition everyone
we would walk through this thing and I
would be like and there would be like
this text explaining this art exhibition
at the end Sydney Sydney was always
already in the next [ __ ] room and I
was like wait a minute I'm reading this
and then I read it and then I'm like
okay now I understand why no one reads
this yeah because like it was okay that
it's it's Instagram bait disguised as an
art museum yeah of course that's what it
is like it's it's made for Instagram
it's a lot of people taking pictures
which is fine nothing wrong with that
but like you're pretend to be some
pretentious art museum is kind of like
well I mean you know I went to meow wolf
uh on the U.S tour which is basically
the American version of Team Labs so
it's like it's it's an interactive Art
Museum but no one actually gives a [ __ ]
about like the art so what was in meow
wolf so meow wolf is very much similar
to team labs in the sense that like it's
separated into like different rooms so
like each room I don't know how it is in
team Labs but at least with meow wolf at
least the one I went in uh in Denver was
um each room is actually done by a
different independent artist so the vibe
and the feel of everything and the
interactivity and the level of
interactivity is completely different in
different rooms yeah um so and there
isn't usually like one theme of the
entire place it's it's like all over the
[ __ ] place whereas like team Labs is
kind of like the theme I feel like kind
of flows into one another so it feels
like just one big exhibition right and
then lots of little small exhibitions
right
um and I feel like at least the at least
meow wolf is a lot more like I don't
know it's kind of like teen Labs on
crack it's just like it's just sensory
overload right whereas team Labs is a
little more like subtle and more like
ambient in in its feel right it's like
oh okay this is kind of a nice calming
environment that is also very aesthetic
and Instagram worthy yeah because uh
there are some exhibitions where there
are some pieces where I was just like
I'll be honest I don't get it like there
was there was one exhibition where you
had to like take your shoes off because
there's there's a lot a lot of Team Labs
um there are some exhibitions where I
can get up to like knee-high water yeah
yeah and here I am working like boots on
the [ __ ] jeans and I'm like oh I'm
going to have a bad time but luckily I
could just roll my jeans up it's pretty
cool though yeah it's very cool but that
was like one exhibition where the the
exhibition is you walking up uh you
walking up like a slight incline and
then there's like warm water trickling
down oh yeah mind you this water doesn't
smell like spring water it's very
clearly chlorine water yeah so it just
smells like swimming pool right because
God knows how many people are walking in
this water and then I remember I
remember like oh this is this is a cool
entrance to an exhibition right this is
a cool entrance to whatever they're
about to show us and then I walk up I
reach the top of the hill
um I've reached the next room and then
there's a plaque explaining that that
was the exhibition I was like what I
thought that was like the entrance to
the art piece I didn't know that was a
[ __ ] art piece itself well what was
the explanations that we've made a [ __ ]
River
yeah
was it worth the money would you say
um if you post on Instagram I didn't
take any pictures unfortunately you
didn't take any pictures did you really
go can't wait hold on
you are I think you are the only person
I've ever heard of that has gone to team
labs and not taken a photo literally the
only person on Earth to ever go there
and I'll take a picture yeah I took
photos with Sydney uh
[Music]
but then there was like another there
was like another R piece as well where
it was basically this room that was just
it was padded from like ceiling to like
floor and like all the walls padded with
like bean bags and stuff like that and
you could like you you couldn't like
walk on it
uh without [ __ ] falling over or
something because like you it was just
so well padded that you would sink in
and like the whole point of that is that
um I can't remember what's the message
okay I'll I'll try and remember what the
message was because I was reading this
and I was just like this is I I I don't
[ __ ] get this so it's like uh since
the World is Flat we've forgotten that
we can affect each other right so when
so hold on did you just start off with
the World is Flat
since we since was this made by flano
it's like we all know the world is
or a flat floor it forgets the effect we
can have on our fellow human being
um so because the message I got because
I remember that room the message I got
out of that room is oh it's like a
McDonald's playpen this is fun the
message I got of that room is twitchcon
could [ __ ] never man switch con could
never
this is what twitchcon wanted
they didn't have enough phone for this
[ __ ] what
was it I think I remember one of the the
cool rooms in team Labs I think it was
like uh it was covered it was this kind
of hallway that was covered in like very
very light string just like yeah that
was the coolest one that had like lights
attached to it oh yeah and the lights
would kind of like Flicker and like wave
back and forth as you were like kind of
wait waving through this like sea of
lights that was really cool what's the
message behind that I don't know that
was that was I I just I just remember
going through a lot of like the
exhibitions in team Labs
um like a scene in John Wick that's
always thought of it like this is like
the penultimate scene where Jonah just
to kill like the the main bad guys like
bodyguard right and then it's always in
like one of those art things right it's
like everything so everything's a mirror
yeah it was reflective and there's
lights and he's almost gonna fight them
there was a room in meow wolf actually
where the entire thing was just full of
mirrors yeah it's just I just like it's
pretty cool they've been pulling that
trick since like a circus stage in the
1900s I know but I've never been in one
and so when I went in one I was like oh
this is true
mirrors never what let's see every like
shitty Carnival has one I never went to
a carnival they don't have Carnival they
don't have shitty carnivals in Australia
maybe they do but my parents never took
me a while
yeah I I think I think my biggest
takeaway after going out of like that
like interactive art experience is that
it's a [ __ ] travesty that you would
make this in the country where every
[ __ ] uh every drug is illegal it's
just like it's it's a it's a natural
[ __ ] travesty you know like yeah
that is true
that's funny it's like it's like you
don't need drugs just use your
imagination
and read the writing on the walls that
no one [ __ ] reads because because I'm
going through and I'm like this this is
an exhibition that just was seemed to be
made for like a country where you you
pop an edible or something ago and you
and you go enjoy the experience you know
that's that just it just seems like that
was what this experience was Taylor Made
for and obviously that's that's not a
thing in Japan so no man museums in
Japan are either like amazing or so so
bad and normally they're bad what's a
good Museum
I think a good museum is one that where
you know nothing of the source material
or what it's based on or what it's what
it's there to cover and it can engage
you yeah so I think like you know have
you been to the Natural History Museum
in the UK that's really cute like I
don't [ __ ] care about dinosaurs maybe
I'm maybe I'm like the one person I
don't know I don't know I don't care
about dancing people say they don't care
about dinosaurs but no one like no one
actively like deep down there is the
five-year-old you that's the yeah
Tyrannosaurus
don't give a [ __ ] someone says they
don't care about dinosaurs I'm like bet
there's there's a bone in your body
that's just like it's like a really like
everything in that museum is so well
made and all the information is
presented in such a really cool way yeah
you know and when you go into like the
dinosaur exhibition it's you literally
walk in and all of these like elements
explaining everything about dinosaurs
and stuff yeah literally above you is a
giant [ __ ] like dinosaurs like
skeleton yeah yeah really cool Rick and
packed she's really busy because
dinosaurs are cool because dinosaurs are
sick and even like even like the stuff
where it's like the the Bug Museum part
of it I'm like that's [ __ ] sick yeah
that's awesome given there are some
topics that are easier to present uh in
museums than others I think animals like
one of the easier ones yeah yeah but
like something like ass is like I'm like
[ __ ] I don't I don't know how you would
get me interested in that I I I said
I've been to our galleries before yeah
um
and it's uh let's just say it's not for
me you know that's just that's a really
populism I really I'm gonna I'm like
[ __ ] man I wish this was quiet but then
when I get in a really quiet Museum like
[ __ ] I'd love some something some just
some cough or something yeah there's
something there's there's like a balance
of like the amount of people in an
exhibit right like because I remember
like I don't have I I don't really have
time to do it anymore but I remember
when I first moved to Japan I had this
like period of like six or seven months
where I used to go to the the you know
the Mori Arts Museum in Roppongi there's
this there's this art museum in Roppongi
uh like in roponky Hills where the old
YouTube headquarters used to be oh is
that um where they have that weird like
[ __ ] like stranger things ass monster
thing looking statue yeah the spider
yeah right [ __ ] creepy whatever that
thing is but basically on the top floor
of uh one of the buildings there they
have this thing called the moriarts
museum and I think it's like every
somewhere the anime stuff goes a lot of
animes I went to the I went to the
almost Neverland one yeah oh I was like
I don't know what the [ __ ] this is yeah
but basically it's like I think it's
like every couple of months they switch
out the exhibits to like new things
sometimes it's like anime exhibits
sometimes it's you know just like uh an
independent artist sometimes it's like
maybe like dinosaurs or something
thematic yeah and I had a period for
like uh maybe like the first year or so
where I would go to the moriarts museum
like every other month just to see what
was there because I think the way that
they did it was really cool because it's
like obviously if it was like an anime
Museum like I went to the attack on
Titan Museum there and like the Sailor
Moon exhibit there and like those they
did a ton of those but then there was
somewhere it's just like an independent
artist where it's like I've never heard
of this person or what they do but let's
go check it out and I think the moriarts
museum does it in a cool way because
it's kind of like a lot of it is like a
lot of Contemporary Arts where it's kind
of like team Labs where it's it's not
necessarily interactive but it kind of
is is it isn't just like here's some
paintings on a wall yeah you know it's
very much like sculptures or like whole
room exhibits or like you know something
to do with like lighting or something
like that where it's like a little more
interesting than just being like yes the
the paintwork on this is is is exquisite
you know it's like and it's like I don't
have a problem with that kind of Art
Exhibit as well like I've been to the
Louvre and stuff like that and a lot of
it is like that but like there's more
history behind that right yeah and
that's that's the interesting part to me
yeah I mean that with those kinds that's
more like a museum yeah in my mind
because you're seeing like actual real
history you're single
kind of experiencing a part of history
and stuff like that yeah and you know
there has been art that has like
impressed me and stuff like that but I
feel like one you really need to be in
the right mood to be there because then
you know why you need to be on the right
drugs
depending on who you ask
yeah because like unless there's some
kind of interesting way to display this
information yeah no matter if you're if
it's like an art museum or if it's just
a museum about whatever right if it's
just this display and just text next to
it it's just that's I've I've never
found that interesting at all yeah it
feels like I'm just scrolling through a
Wikipedia article yeah you know I think
like one of the really cool ones I
remember going uh to seeing the moriarts
uh Museum was uh this independent
Japanese contemporary artist who does a
lot of like uh exhibits and paintings
but all of her Works uh kind of play
around with like this idea of
perspective yeah so there's like there
was a piece I remember the black and
white one uh I don't know if it's the
black and white one but there was one
where like one of the rooms you walk
into and the entire room looks like the
inside of a train but when you look on
either side of the walls the walls are
actually like skewed in so it so when
you look straight down it it looks like
the wall goes way further than it
actually does and it looks like you're
like actually looking down a carriage of
a train and like stuff like that is cool
because it's like it's again it's not
just like painting and some text yeah
you know if anything I think that
exhibit like that entire exhibit there
was no like text to read about it was
kind of just like a go see it for
yourself feel how you feel interpreted
how you interpret it and like post your
pictures yeah like you know it's I I
like the kind of exhibits where it's
like it gives you the space to interpret
how you want to interpret it like if you
want to find that to be cool then sick
if you just look at it and be like yeah
all right then you're free to do so kind
of yeah because like what how did feel
about the anime art exhibits or the monk
the manga exhibits that pop up every now
so yeah and because I've been to a lot
of them are you going to convince me
it's anything but a glorified way to get
exclusive merch I mean that is
definitely true I feel like that's why
like 90 people go to them yeah yeah yeah
that's why I go to 90
because I'm like I'm like I'm
in the original panels pretty dope yeah
you know like see like you know like
when I went to like the berserk exhibit
for example right I was like [ __ ]
seeing like Mira's art and [ __ ] like
that was like you know up close and
personal was [ __ ] amazing but I want
that limited edition painting though
it's like every time I see a new a new
like anime or Manga exhibit I'm like oh
they decided to do a pop-up store and an
extra exhibit on top of that you know
it's it's it's it's nice and I think
berserk is one of the few examples I
think of that could really work because
Mira's art is [ __ ] insane yeah and I
think it would be insane to see his
original manuscripts and everything like
that actually I think one of the best
anime exhibits I ever went to was
probably the Barky one uh that they did
a Tokyo Dome because it's like it's not
only you get to see like up close and
personal you know itagaki's like panels
and you know art and stuff like that but
they also had interactive elements so
like in the middle of the exhibit they
basically recreated like the the under
the Tokyo Dome like battle area with
like full on Sand and everything and
that little details of like little bits
of like teeth and Nails on the ground
and [ __ ] and like there's a statue of
Balki that you can like stand next to
and take a photo with but it looks like
you're fighting Bucky in the underground
like stuff like that I think is makes
standard like anime exhibits way cooler
like it's still cool like if you like
the artist or you know you like the the
look of the manga whatever just going to
go see the original stuff as a fan is
dope but like it gives you more of an
excuse I guess to like you know actually
be part of the experience if you have
something there that's not just let's
just look at some manga panels you know
yeah yeah a lot of them that I've been
to are just literally like behind the
scenes panels and it's like okay if I'm
really into that that's cool yeah a lot
of times I'm kind of like okay well I
mean I kind of like that I've already
I've already seen it yeah I feel like
they're like oh it took him two days to
write this I'm like okay well but I need
to come here to find that out like right
right A lot of the times I'm just like
why go to a physical location like yeah
and cool yeah maybe some behind the
scenes or early panels or mock-ups
that's cool yeah like for me it's like
yeah yeah
I didn't go to it yeah yeah The Barking
what I didn't like about the Bucky one
though is the fact that that the add-on
that they decided to tack onto it was a
Bucky themed Cafe which oh those they
always Japan does every single [ __ ]
time but like the Bucky one especially I
was like wow you guys took the laziness
of like incorporating the elements of
baki with standard Cafe food to the next
level they had like they had like
[ __ ] carbonara that was themed after
that's okay and I'm like
one there was not a single moment in
Baki where datsu is eating carbonara and
two when you look at the picture it's
literally just a plate of carbonara with
like a paper cut out of nitza's face red
suit the Chinese guy yeah the Chinese
guy okay oh okay and I'm like you
weren't even gonna like match with
Chinese food you gave him [ __ ]
carbonara I think a lot of the times I
I'm just speculating on how it works but
I think a lot of them are like
outsourced cafes it's like whatever the
cafe can make yeah for sure so you just
kind of like yeah [ __ ] put their face
on it but at least like you know I've
been to some of them are good though
yeah I've been to some themey cafes
where like the food actually matches
like the theme of whatever it is like
that's the reason why it's easier though
yeah like certain shows lines way better
to having absolutely food than others
yeah so I totally get it but it's like
at that point if you're gonna go so far
as to like not even put the effort to
like at least try and get close to the
theme of whatever themed Cafe it is then
like what's the point in wasting your
time and money on it well
[Music]
I go to Every exhibition and I swear 90
of the people are waiting in the merch
line and it's like 10 are in the actual
exhibit exactly yeah when I I went to
the a bunch of few cafes at amaleks
Emily's obsessed with them yeah I don't
know how she's doing videos about them
and we went to the um I don't know I
don't spoil a video but went to the
Banana Fish Cafe and there was there was
merch and my God it was like one of the
matches was that you could um you could
buy a pre-packaged cookie it's a cookie
like not but it's like it's like the
outside packaging is themed for like an
artist yeah I guess yeah because I guess
how much the cookie was
like literally a Starbucks cookie that
you could buy 400 Yen fibers like 900
Yen what the [ __ ] that's a cookie
that you're probably not gonna eat
because you don't want to ruin the
package anything special no no you
should [ __ ] cookies it wasn't even
banana flavored I don't even think it's
bananas flavored uh and again like this
food is always just so meh yeah I hate
going to these places like I'm like I've
wasted one of my my color caloric intake
meals on this and I paid a premium for
it if I I would have rather have gone to
McDonald's like literally anything else
like why I just food is my one joy in
life and these cafes rob it from me and
I get I get so sad when I go to them
yeah yeah which is why I like I think I
really appreciate it when I do find a
themed Cafe that actually gives a [ __ ]
about trying to I've never been to one
where I thought the food was good okay
because the only one I've been to that I
thought was good was the Kirby Cafe I've
heard that one's pretty good actually
yeah the booking is like nuts you feel
like like all the semi-decent cafe with
the book like 10 years in advance yeah
like two months in advance yeah the
Pokemon but even then like I've been to
the Pokemon cafe a few times and it's
like if the food is good like it's
better than the standard themed Cafe but
still it's like it's [ __ ] in Cafe
it's hard especially when it's a pop-up
too to make food that's even remotely
good because it's well that's why the
Kirby one is good because that's a
permanent one at right yeah it's like a
Sky Tree they have more time yeah and
it's like the food the food items that
they have and like how they present it
is actually matches the theme of the
Kirby Universe I'm like oh they actually
put some [ __ ] effort into it and the
merch is actually good like okay
question because you've been you've been
to Disneyland yeah do you like the
Disneyland food do you think Disney okay
because like people always try and lie
to me and tell me that it's good and
every time I've been I've hated the food
I've only liked the popcorn that's
literally it like I don't think I've had
a single meal or snack at Disneyland
where I'm just like yes this is worth
coming back yeah yeah you know how
everyone wants to uh you can actually
have turkey legs yeah it's like a thing
yeah bro it was vile I hated this thing
it was disgusting I do I I never
understood like I'd never wanted to
become a vegetarian I never had any part
of my brain that made me think that I
should become a vegetarian but seeing
that kind of disgusting like veiny gross
like like red like bright red turkey leg
that I'm just chewing into made me
forget it I was like you know what yeah
no I get it this is this is eating
animals like this is disgusting like
this it doesn't even taste good like if
it tasted Divine I'd be like all right
well sorry turkeys yeah see but then
Disneyland Disneyland fans will come
back on that argument and be like well
yeah but like the point of Disneyland
isn't the food it's it's a lot of them
swear by it though it's the World
building it's the World building and
then take me out of it knowing that like
[ __ ] Donald Duck or Mickey Mouse is a
[ __ ] chef and he should have a cup
like honestly the best food I had in
Disneyland which did standard ass hot
dog
but that's because you're talking yeah
hot dog and you're like it's all right
that's all right I was asleep
you're right as long as it snaps yeah
have you been to Disneyland in Japan yet
no do you plan to and I have no
intentions
if I didn't if I didn't go during the
pandemic there's no [ __ ] way I've
been to Disneyland and see now and both
of them were fine just fine
just not a Disney guy you know and nor
is Sydney she's not doing yeah I'm very
lucky huh you're very lucky that your
partner isn't like Disney obsessed I
feel like it becomes a nightmare once
they are
because you're owned by the Disney
Corporation yeah because she is and it's
so and it's so it's so I don't wanna say
it's horrible but it's so like asinine
because she got into it not because of
Disney but because of Kingdom Hearts so
it's like extra
there's always an Avenue
side and the Kingdom Heart size so it's
just like a double whammy but at least
she doesn't like drag me to go to
Disneyland because she knows I don't
like it so it's like that's fine you can
go to Disneyland it's cold I know you've
paid the taxes yeah you've been to a
theme park with a theme park obsessed
person yeah oh my God it's the worst my
uh my cousin actually my younger cousin
used to have the Disney yearly pass uh
which is like you I don't know how much
it is yeah it costs like four tickets
yeah but like I think like I actually
did the calculations it's like it's only
worth the money if you end up going to
Disneyland I think it's like at least
two or three times a month yeah I don't
I said really I thought it was way less
I thought it was like five times a year
I think it's something like it's at
least in the Japanese one it's like two
to three times a mark but my cousin used
to go every week I've never like been a
guy who like I I like theme parks I like
anything I like throw pops
I would never think about going to like
a Thrill Park or theme park more than
twice a year like ever yeah I don't know
that's just maybe my mind just like
programmed that way but once I've seen
everything once I'm like okay that was
cool I don't need to go again for a
while you know yeah they actually uh
she took it off the website actually
because it's the yearly pass the animal
passports oh yeah probably probably
because of the pandemic though right
yeah I mean you know when you go with
someone who's obsessed they're like they
have an itinerary in their head and if
if you don't stick to it they get so
annoyed they're like they're like I'm
like what if I don't want to do that
right they're like no you have to I I
optimal way because I have I have
friends who are Disneyland obsessed but
they don't like going on rides they
literally go to Disneyland just to take
photos what the [ __ ] and I'm just like
Emmett you do you don't involve me now
it's a Disneyland Disneyland uh Team
Labs exhibition that's that's basically
what it is
basically basically it's not exhibition
yeah it's like I don't want the
interactivity I just want to take the
photos I don't know if maybe you know
doing a ton of Anime conventions you
just turned me off this but I just don't
enjoy being in places with when I'm
shoulder to shoulder with people no so
I've never it's like I feel like I I
just don't want to be I've never been
that way but I think being two enough
Anime conventions has just put me off
that even more yeah because I'm like God
damn nothing is more suffocating than
being in a room full of weebs and
someone there [ __ ] stinks and uh you
go on pinpoint who's Disneyland well you
know you know somewhere you know someone
here stinks well luckily Disneyland is
not as bad but
unless unless there's a webinar not even
Disneyland but [ __ ] just like the
thought of going to Kyoto now just like
turns me off so much yeah for sure I
just don't think anything in my mind is
worth being like shoulder to shoulder
stuck to people I'm just kind of like
actually I'd rather just not I'm good
like maybe I miss out on some cool
things but ultimately I just don't want
to have to line up for like three hours
for anything or just be shorter to
shoulder yeah I've I've realized like
I've grown too big like pet peeves like
growing up now that I just like have
like zero tolerance for and one of them
is like uh one of them is being in a big
crowded in a big Space full of crowded
people yeah and the second one is just
queuing up for an experience I guess
and Disneyland is both of them like okay
okay like if they're if if I really want
to go to a restaurant right yeah and you
have a restaurant that's like highly
acclaimed
um really got got really good reviews
but you have to wait half an hour for or
a restaurant that has no weight that
serves the same Cuisine but has lower
rated reviews I'm going to I'm going for
that one every single day I mean Japan
loves lion up for stuff yeah I mean
there's that on a Gary place we have to
wait two hours to get it on a Geary yeah
an onigiri that's like waiting up four
hours of beans on toast in the UK I look
at you like that and I'm just like how
much better could it be no it can't it
can't there's no way it can be worth
waiting two hours I refuse to believe it
hey maybe I'll get proven wrong and I'll
try it and I'll numb my pants right
unless they're like sprinkling that
onigiri with cocaine or something it's
like it's not worth it there's no way I
I refuse to believe there's even a I've
never waited that long for any food and
I thought that was worth it yeah ever
ever like but then again yeah but then
again like Japan and the concept of like
Foodies especially in Japan is is on
another level like there are there are
lots of like I know food obsessed like
Foodies all over the world that you know
you've seen and stuff like that but like
in Japan they just like when it comes to
food they just like living in an
entirely different Universe give me a
time when I can book and come in and
then I will I will wait three months for
the bookings yeah experience this thing
if if needs be but if I need to like you
up I'm like no
that's where I draw the line because
then there are the there are [ __ ]
stalls that are just like so up
themselves and they're like yeah people
are willing to wait so uh we're not
actually gonna allow bookings you just
have to get there early enough and I'm
like every time I see stores like that
I'm like I [ __ ] hate you I'm sure
your food is delicious but [ __ ] you I
think sometimes the ones that don't
allow bookings like really popular
restaurants or chains that know that
they'll have a consistent customer base
yeah and in their mind you know having
this table blocked off that could hold
maybe eight people yeah you know maybe
that's uh you know a ton of customers
you're losing out on that could be
coming through yeah and maybe this
bucking doesn't even show so maybe in
their business model because they're so
popular it makes way more sense to not
have reservations also it is kind of
nice being able to just turn up to some
nice restaurants and if you're lucky and
there's two of you it's like oh cool we
can just get a seat right now right but
that's nice so I think there are pros
and cons of everything yeah for sure but
[ __ ] no I'm not waiting two hours
I'm going to like Denny's I'm not I'm
not waiting that long I'm straight up
like yeah I just I I feel like my time
is the most important aspect to me yeah
and I feel insulted when someone's like
hey you've got to wait two hours for
onigiri I'm like it's like no I'm going
to the family room I'm sorry
I like the 7-Eleven one yeah I'm chill
with it being yeah fine don't eat this
yeah so we talked about like museums and
like you know like not really like
vibing with art exhibitions and stuff
like that how do you guys feel about
guided tours I hate them hate them
something we all agree about finally
unless the tour guide is an absolute
goat and loves his job and is like super
knowledgeable and super like upbeat like
I have seen some tour guides who you're
like okay damn I want to be on this tour
but like most of them are just hey this
happens to be a really historical area
with a lot of stuff going on we paid
some guy who's kinda into it like he
doesn't really care yeah he's just
following let's just let's just recite a
script yeah you know like London stuff
the most interesting people uh to ask
about London and local London like
traditions or places just normally like
cab drivers yeah they know London they
show well and they're so passionate
about it yeah I got on the cab one time
and the guy just happened to be a
certified tour guide in London and he
gave me like so many good
recommendations of pubs and places to go
eat for like really good stuff that I
never knew even when I was living there
right and that was way better than going
on some guided tour that you pay out of
the ass for with some guy really
uninspiredly talked about talked to you
about London right like I feel that it's
such a it's such a mixed bag where it's
just not worth it a lot of the time and
also [ __ ] Kevin walk around for two
hours on some guided tour I just want to
do my own thing yeah yeah oh that's the
thing like I I get why guidance
because like I get I get why guided
tours exist right because you know for a
lot of people who aren't used to
traveling and you know maybe a little
bit worried about you know potentially
going to some place that's a little like
uh or you know potentially scared to
have it not as good as an experience
yeah right it's good for school yeah
it's good for school kids yeah but like
but then I I also think that's what put
me off tour guides officially because
yeah every time we went on a tour guide
school trip it was the most boring ass
[ __ ] thing of all time
[ __ ] school trips of coal mines yeah
coal mines yeah because Wales you had a
massive cold boom uh in like I think
like the 50s 60s I think there's tons of
coal mines in Wales I remember I went to
one which was uh
just processing that right okay
history and now these kids in Minecraft
are they yearning for the minds right so
yeah we went to these mines right and uh
we would literally just go into the mine
like straight up just go into it they'd
be like this is where they would mind
the cold yeah would you say would you
say that was the worst guided tour that
you ever went on because the worst one
for me was uh we got taken to a sewage
Plantation
uh when we were like I think like eighth
grade uh because there was one right
near our high school
um okay and uh they were like yeah it's
just like it's like 10 minutes there's a
few things in my high school I don't
think they'd filmed it's like 15 minutes
by bus so uh let's go check out how uh
your your [ __ ] is uh processed and we
went there and a it was boring as [ __ ]
and B smelled like [ __ ] two kids fainted
because of how bad it smells and I'm
just like and I'm just like teacher why
did you this is like a punishment this
is not I'm not learning anything other
than the fact that yes indeed poop does
smell very bad you smell bad who smell
bad I knew that yeah that was my father
stinky oh oh stinky what pass out why
did they take you to a sewage plan
I don't know because they're I guess
like the teacher was like let's find out
how uh you know this kind of uh you know
these kinds of Dirty Jobs exist and
people need to you know do this kind of
thing and it's it's good for the
environment it's good for the oceans and
stuff like that so let's let's find out
have you ever wondered how what happens
after you've flush your toilet and and
all the kids are like no actually uh I'm
sure it goes to some [ __ ] Plantation
but uh do I care about how it's
processed not really I'd rather do a
sewage tour plan uh than do some kind of
over tourist thing like do a tour of
Venice or something yeah yeah that's too
bad I think I did that one time my
parents I remember thinking like oh this
is so boring so boring yeah yeah I I
kind of like coming to this realization
as an adult because for the longest time
I just thought I don't like history I'm
I'm just not a history I love history
yeah I I'm just gonna realization that
no history if history [ __ ] slaps
history is like so interesting but I
just thought he was so boring as a kid
because it was taught to me in the most
like boring ass man I'm exactly the same
I I just like I was just like damn I
hated history class but as an adult when
you get to pick and choose what history
you want to die you know do a full dive
into it's fascinating as [ __ ] I mean
yeah I think you should I think as a kid
I was just always like this is insane
like 50 years ago it's like a totally
different place yeah that's so cool yeah
but like in different periods of time
it's essentially just a different Human
Experience altogether I'm sure that's
what I like I'm sure a little bit of
that I felt as well as a student but it
was just set again it was just taught to
me in such an asinine way where it's
just like I feel like I'm just like
listening to someone recite the
dictionary to me it's just like it's not
fun like like even we had like some
school trips where we went to uh you
know some famous places where
um it's like some famous battles
happened in like the history of England
and I I look back at these battles I'm
like these this is like some [ __ ]
Game of Thrones kind of [ __ ] right it's
it's a it's it's actually like insane
the [ __ ] that was going on but I
remember going to the school trip and as
a kid for like the Battle of Hastings
right
no we did we went to
we went to the tapestry in France I
think right you know where they have the
they are tapestry the really wrong thing
about the Battle yeah uh Hastings are
1066 right 10 16 yeah
um and uh yeah I mean if you know it was
a very famous historic battle that you
know changed the time in the UK yeah
change the tide of like British like
English History and everything like that
um and you know we went to like some of
the fields where the battles took place
and I remember as a kid it just I just
found it I just find it so hard to
immerse myself in what someone's telling
me when someone's like just
like citing or facts in the most
monotone way yeah because they were just
like and this is where the battle took
place where all of these people died and
everything like that and I'm just like
it's a [ __ ] field why are we here
it's a field obviously we have a ton of
castles in Wales and we did some school
trips to some castles and there was like
uh you could do like a peasant
experience or something
like you I do that every day of my life
thank you very much I was like Wow
peasant simulator I was like this is
fascinating couldn't be me no I remember
we went into like um
we had to yeah do a bunch of things that
like the average peasant would do right
yeah and we would eat what they would
eat and of course bread and soup yeah it
was just that sounds interesting though
yeah yeah but as a kid you're like as a
kid it was kind of cool but as an adult
I'm like nice
you scammed me no it was cool I tell a
lie I think at the time I actually
really enjoyed that stuff more because
like they yeah you know I thought that
was really cool as a kid because they
would actually make you get involved in
the history like it wasn't like we would
just tell you and this is what they ate
it was like Hey kids where where these
because we would dress up as well like
The Peasants
like that's at least that at least
there's like an interactive elements
there yeah and then we would like they
never let us do anything cool even if it
is questionable
I just have this image of like the
adults being and then the child dressed
up as the peasant
they wouldn't say that but that's now
what I'm remembering it being uh because
you know it was it was like they would
make yeah we would have to like I
remember we would have to make the soup
with the help of the pizza foreign
thing we had to do where like God I
don't know I have such a vivid memory of
this I think in some parts they would um
I think like Christmas or something I
can't remember when you would do this
we spent like an hour just you had an
orange and you would just put clothes
like clothes into it I like the really
smelly things what are they are they
called they called clubs right oh cloves
very aromatic things yeah
stab an orange full of these and they'll
be like it would make the room smell
nice I don't know why but that's what we
did and that's how Connor grew his hate
towards orange juice
we did a few other things we didn't
really do anything like super cool like
I remember they would like show us where
they would train they wouldn't let us
like touch anything obviously because
why would you let a five-year-old touch
a sword oh that would have been badass
yeah I think it was pretty cool though
yeah I think like again like I I
wouldn't mind guided tours and stuff
like that if again there was that some
level of interactivity right because
like again it's like as a kid or even as
an adult if you just [ __ ] stand
around and look at something while a
person explains you being like use your
imagination to imagine what it was like
what it looked like a thousand years ago
then it's like okay you know history
Buffs will be like Oh okay that's kind
of rad I'm standing on a piece of
history but to the average person you'd
just be like it's [ __ ] field in it
yeah like what what what am I supposed
to do with this information it's like oh
I'm sick all right like it's it's it's
always like even in as an adult that's
why don't really go to a lot of like
touristy places because you know if if
you tell if you tell me if you tell me
something happens there and even if I go
to the place it doesn't like help me
immerse myself in it yes I actually like
find a way to get myself yeah unless you
find a way to get me can't to care about
what's being said you know unless
someone's actually passionate about it
you know I've been to [ __ ] Stonehenge
it's fun it's a bunch of [ __ ] rocks
it's a bunch of [ __ ] rocks okay you
could you could tell me that this was
the most historical site of like the
earlier side of man it's a bunch of
[ __ ] rocks okay was the most
disappointing thing I've ever seen in my
life I couldn't [ __ ] believe well we
British like to disappoint like it was
like it looked better from the highway
yeah like then it does up close I'm like
wow that's a that's a first yeah I look
at like the Great Pyramids of Giza I'm
like that's a [ __ ] sight man that's a
story like that that is somewhere I
wanna [ __ ] actually go to and check
out and then if you look at what you're
like Mom we have a historical site at
home and that's the historical thing we
have the pyramids
have you seen like videos like at the
pyramids it's like there's so much trash
oh yeah so much like and there's like uh
no scalpers um people hackling you
trying to sell you stuff yeah this is
like okay it's like that's when you're
like wow I feel like a tourist yeah I
think that's a problem right when you
when you get when you're made to feel
like you are just a cog in a moving pot
it doesn't feel genuine like it feels
like okay you're here for my money and
I'm leaving yeah not that any place has
owes you to make you feel like you
matter in any capacity but like when you
when you feel like you're there and
you're Chicago indisposable it feels
weird like if you think that's why
Disney's done so well like it's their
credit they make they try and make it
feel like people who are into it like
you are like you're in Disney yeah you
are not we welcome you with open arms
everyone's so nice to you right it's all
it's all perfect right it's all like
choreographed perfectly I think that's
why people like it so well because when
you go to Disney like a lot of people
feel like they're you know that it's a
part of them like it's like a real real
connection they have to it and the
Disney World and land just helped
perpetuate that yeah for sure whereas
when you go to like [ __ ] Venice
you're like Jesus Christ this is awful I
can't wait to leave it's like oh I I
can't believe I'm looking at the
Coliseum yeah like seven people are
trying I I love this I can't wait to buy
a coffee for 15 [ __ ] Euros yeah it
tastes like [ __ ] it's like just just
just immerse yourself in the history
because there's like 20 people taking
selfies behind oh yeah so many tourists
Chinese tourists just shouting at the
top of their lungs and it's just like I
can't immerse myself in this holy [ __ ]
like yeah I remember going to like the
Great Wall of China and it was it's got
to be packed
like shoulder to shoulder man I was
looking at one of the greatest like one
of the greatest things man kind of has
ever built and all I can think pretty
[ __ ] longer in it it's pretty it's
pretty [ __ ] long in it yeah that was
the takeaway it's like oh it's a big
wall in it it was pretty [ __ ] long
yeah so is the M25 though you know that
goes on for miles
all right sort of thing that was like a
news article these two boys are running
across the Great Wall of Trials I can't
be that [ __ ] long is it and I googled
that I was like [ __ ] hell that's long
I was like they could have done one
tenth of that leg I'm pretty sure it
still would have been great yeah
genuinely like I someone should have
told them hey how long is the green Wich
100 miles holy [ __ ] right am I crazy
it's like 100 miles something right it
should have done 20 miles pretty sure it
still would have been pretty great okay
I I see why they call it the Great Wall
not just the wall
it's not the okay it is
[Music]
what's the cutoff between good and great
so total length of the sections of the
Great Wall of China it adds up to a
thousand uh 13
171 miles isn't that insane thoughts
yeah so 21
196 kilometers
it's more than great that's [ __ ]
insane yeah to think about everything
being being on the actual wall with uh
like especially in like one of the big
entrances yeah you don't think that at
all you're like well have you seen like
um there's a series that uh with Carl
Pilkington yeah where he basically just
made this guy who uh if you don't like
carpool is kind of this very average
British man right who just doesn't like
anything yeah and so it sounds like yeah
he forced him to get all this touristy
stuff and he just hated it all right and
dude they made the Great Wall of China
and that episode looks so Bleak and
awful they made it because it's just
like he's on this bus on the way to it
and it's just a bunch of like people
like spitting yeah like it made it like
seem really Bleak and kind of like oh
before you get there there's trash
everywhere and it's just like it's just
packed one thing um that I've not seen
anyone talk about uh the Great Wall of
China
um so I I remember
um the entrance that I went on the Great
Wall of China it's it was it was one of
the most popular kind of places because
obviously the Great Wall is [ __ ]
massive yeah there's I'm sure there's a
lot more aesthetic pleasing places where
do you walk and then get out another
section or do you walk and then turn
back around uh so you're walking and
there's a station and then there's a
cable car that takes you up to the Great
Wall of China technology yeah which is
uh not very ancient China I'm sort of
didn't have that in the [ __ ]
um hand Dynasty or whatever but you know
um but there's a cable car that takes
you up so you're you're stuck you're
you're basically stuck on there until
you can take the cable car back down
right
um so you go up and it's it's [ __ ]
round right yeah it's absolutely uh
absolutely round of tourists and the
Cobblestone there's been so many
tourists that the Cobblestone is just
smooth like there there were steps there
were steps but it was more like a slide
right because because they had been
eroded so much by so many people walking
on walking on the stones right the one
thing people don't talk about really
they talk about the history or something
uh which is which is amazing the history
insane yeah it's [ __ ] insane you go
up there the first thing I noticed is
that something smells funny right it's
not something something smells funny in
the air and I can't can't I can't
pinpoint it right
um but then I soon realize what this
funny smell was I went in summer by the
way
um I went in summer
um so I uh on this wall since we're
stuck on the wall we you have to go take
a cable car down to get off the wall and
obviously the line's [ __ ] massive
um I didn't go to the toilet before
going on the Great Wall of China
um of course there'd be no toilets and
the Great Wall of China yeah why would
they why would they install Plumbing
yeah so obviously obviously in hindsight
you're like yeah of course obviously
they um they didn't have Plumbing back
in the the ancient China but since this
is a heavy touristy Place obviously
there's going to be some public toilets
there are they like porta potties or
something
yeah and uh I don't know how they get
[ __ ] off the Great Wall of China but a
lot of [ __ ] stays on the ground of China
and walking towards the public toilet
was one of the worst it was it was like
a Dark Souls boss right you know you you
like just to get through the public
toilet you have to like play the gates
of mortal yeah you have to [ __ ] fight
through a wall of stench as you're like
walking towards this horrible like this
this group of port-a-potties like the
poison it was yeah because like I was
like I can hold my breath but you needed
to be like an Olympic diver to hold your
breath for long enough to get close
enough to like go to the toilet and go
out it was it was one of the worst
Dentures I've ever felt like
um disgusting it's uh yeah if you're
gonna go to the Great Wall of China I
highly recommend not going to the heavy
touristy places before as well and take
a [ __ ] before as well it's because it's
it's an amazing piece of human history
it looks amazing I really wanted a
butter God [ __ ] damn it like the the
heavily tourist spots are just it's it's
a nightmare I mean for how long the Wall
is there must be like blank spots right
where you can go to the wall and there's
maybe like barely anyone there I don't
know I don't know like I don't know how
much of the wall is actually accessible
to the public right like I'm sure
there's a lot of possible like close I
think I think a lot of them all is like
is closed up for like government
protection yeah like that there's only
some parts of the wall that you can go
to but there are less busier parts right
um it just so happens that the part
that's closest to Beijing is obviously
like the uh yeah of course the most
populated part and then the most
stinkiest part of them all and the
father I don't recommend going to even
if it is the Great Wall of China because
it's not a it's it's not a pleasant
experience it's interesting yeah what
was the best tourist spot that you went
to like one whereas like it didn't make
you feel like the kind of bleakness of
like oh this is just a tourist place
that's like taking me for you know
taking my money you know for the sake of
whatever because you know like we've
talked about like how you know you guys
don't really like going to like the
heavily touristy places just for because
of the feeling there's one place I don't
know about the best touristy place I I
have been to but the one place I do want
to go to because that everyone says is
as insane as it looks is the Sistine
Chapel oh in the Vatican yeah in the
Vatican I've I've been there
um it's actually really [ __ ] cool
yeah yeah like you don't even have to
confuse me
yeah no I was trying to remember I was
like that's that's the Sistine Channel
all right yeah no I went there um when I
went to Italy with arky's family
um yeah it's really cool I mean
obviously you have to wait in line for a
long time but the cool thing is is that
they limit
how many people can go in so when you
actually go inside because of the the
just the scale of the building yeah
there's only so many people who are
inside of there so it's actually quite
spaciously you can actually like
probably walk around and you know feel
like the the just the massiveness of the
thing yeah and like I mean you don't
even have to be religious but like the
moment you walk in you just like you
just feel something it's just like this
is like it really is like the most holy
place and it's just I don't know it's
it's such a you're a holy man no not at
all not at all but even then like be me
being in there it just felt so like is
that permanent dude
no no because I I was tempted but
because how echoey it is in there but
like even then like I couldn't even like
someone else joined in when you started
I looked around and I was like on my
Lads with me no not today unfortunately
but like yeah just I don't know like
even if you you're not religious in the
slightest
um like I don't know there's just like
this very strange feeling you get being
in there being like wow this is a very
powerful spot and I can't explain I feel
like that's how like historical Sports
and exhibitions should make yeah I agree
and I feel like a lot of it just get
diluted down by I guess the over
commercialization and the over Taurus
I don't know what the word what I'm
looking for justification
that's a real word we just made that up
there but uh yeah that that kind of
thing where you tell you have this
really really nice place and then it
just gets over touristy yeah um and then
he kind of just ruins that I can't think
of a single place that was super
touristy that I actually enjoyed yeah I
think I just prefer just going to a city
or a place I'm just eating and drinking
the food I think I've said this like a
million times a trash taste yeah it's
like over it I'm a simple man I am a
food and a drink kind of guy yeah I mean
like I I'm also definitely that as well
but if I have the opportunity to see
even just for like a split second like
some kind of touristy section of that
City or whatever like you know unless
it's like super [ __ ] boring or like I
just don't really care like I'll try and
make an effort to go check it out I mean
there's been a lot of instances where
like I've gone to it and I'm like oh
that's kind of underwhelming like when I
went to the Coliseum and so stuff like
that I was just like like you think
about the Coliseum it's like oh this is
[ __ ] amazing piece of architecture
and when I went there I was like yeah it
looks pretty cool anyway see see here's
the thing Joey here's the thing I don't
take pictures yeah I don't post on
Instagram yeah so why would I need to go
to 90 of these spots that people go to
I'll need to take a picture to say that
they've been there yeah you know but you
know what's weird I weirdly actually
don't take pictures in the touristy
spots
because I feel that's like like everyone
does that already right so it's like I
don't mean the [ __ ] toilet
you need to do that anymore like I
rather just take like a picture of like
a normal part of the city or a normal
part of the environment because that's
like more of a I guess like genuine view
of where you are yeah whereas like if I
if if I said like yeah I went to Italy
guys and I took a picture inside the
Sistine Chapel and the [ __ ] and you
know and the Coliseum and everything
then it'll be like okay yeah but like
how is that any different to anybody
else's experience the call seems like so
[ __ ] yeah I didn't even I didn't even
bother going in because there was like a
six hour line and I'm like what I'm good
dog I'm I'm looking it from the outside
yeah it looks pretty sick all right
let's go get some pizza like I I didn't
give a [ __ ] yeah I did I like Italy a
lot but madjo Rome oh I didn't like Rome
either
North Italy is like trying to eat some
food yeah I'm just going around there I
took more pictures in like Florence than
I did in Monroe because it's just like a
nicer City just in general
and it's like there's nothing like
touristy there that I went to but just
like the vibe of that city was just so
much good food though yeah just like
better food and just like the vibe was
better and the people were better it's
just like so much more of an interesting
experience than seeing the [ __ ]
Coliseum yeah every day I just want to
eat food
I believe you just described all living
things
hey I'm unique what can I say but uh hey
look at all these patrons though they're
supporting us do you like going to
touristy places let us know in the
comments
I don't know how to end this episode hey
if you
go to a patreon patreon .com trash taste
also follow us on Twitter since memes on
the subreddit and if you hit our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh we will
see you guys next week bye
foreign
[Music]